ité jailla dans un peu plus d'une heure
lorsque nous saurons qui sont les 30
plus grands chanteurs et chanteuses
français de tous les temps et lorsque
nous saurons qui Trô au sommet de ce
classement bonjour à tous quel défi que
nous nous sommes lancés je vous présente
les sages autour de moi qui auront la
lourde tâche d'établir ce classement
Olivier NC bonjour bonjour Chef du
Service musique du Figaro quotidien oui
merci d'être ici alors je sais que c'est
un projet qui vous pose des problèmes
hein oui on va en parler plus tard oui
bon ne sabordez pas l'émission
immédiatement des choix singuliers je le
sais mon cher Olivier un peu un peu de
la provocation on le droit sais je sais
nicolemou bonjour Le bougon de la
rédaction moi je suis un peu l'imposteur
ici parce que j'écoute quasiment pas de
musique française
ou il y aura pas Paul Macar je vous le
dis tout de
suite rédacteur en chef adjoint du
service culture au figmag c'est ça
Nicolas et puis Florent Florent baraco
serait je crois la caution populaire de
bien sûr je vais défendre la culture de
la variette j'ai eu la liste de noms de
d'Olivier j'ai passé ma soirée sur
Wikipédia donc voilà c'est bon je suis
chaud là Florent directeur adjoint du
figaro.fr bon comment fonctionne ça va
être très simple vous avez ce classement
devant vous pour l'instant il est vide
évidemment et il faut remplir ces 30 non
alors on en a 50 présélectionn 50 ça
s'est fait dans la douleur certains ont
déjà écarté été écarté alors vous pouvez
crier hein il y aura pas Syvie vant pas
cha pas Vanessa Paradis Jean Ferrat
Henry Salvador miosek Pierre Bachelet
Mike Brant Mireille Mathieu il ne sera
pas Mathieu Tino Rossi notre Maria carré
à nous Yugo Fry Nino Ferrer et cetera il
y en a beaucoup qui n'y seront pas mais
nous avons déjà 50 noms ils sont ici
dans ce magnifique pot jaune alors on
peut le montrer tiens Florent montrez-le
voilà vous le montrez il y aura on tire
des noms à chaque fois où est l'issier
excusez-moi ou non il y a pas dehier
c'est moi le patron ici Olivier vous
cherchez pas et puis donc on on essaiera
à chaque fois de les de les classer de
les mettre dans dans ce top 30 il y a
pas de je ne sais Pasin Nicolas vous
savez vous tranchez et vous vous
engueulez s'il faut et on peut pas dire
de dehors directement ah si vous pouvez
dire dehors mais je pense que certains
voudront voudront mettre dans le
classement jean-jac Goldman par exemple
le temps à perdre on commence allez
Olivier NUC vous commencez vous tirez un
nom et puis vous nous le montrez vous
montrez bien la caméra votre caméra est
là-bas ah bah justement voilà justement
voilà Jean-Jacques Goldman Jean-Jacques
Goldman Olivier Nuuk allez-y commencez
votre avis sur jean-jaces Goldman alors
moi je pensais pas qu'on allait traiter
des chanteurs
retraités voilà on a un exemple d'un
chanteur qui a pris sa retraite il y a
20 ans maintenant qui a pas sorti un
disque qui a sorti quelques mauvaises
chansons interprétées par d'autres moi
je l'aimais beaucoup quand j'avais 12
ans mais je pense qu'au-udelà de 12 ans
son écoute est déconseillé voilà ça
c'est l'avis du médecin pour souhaiter
passer de bonne fête rester loin des dis
de jean-jcesman Nicola ngemou moi je
trouve ça tout tout bonnement
abominable voix de fausset parole
débile look
pétique pour moi il y a rien de pire en
dehors de balavine qui voilà ah oui
enfin excusez-moi c'est quand même la
personnalité préférée des Français je
m'en fiche c'est le la référence
musicale populaire des des dernières
années voudrait savoir d'ailleurs qui
sont les sondés si les sondés sont
toujours en vie parce
que si ils on les sondeurs ont peut-être
des fichiers très très anciens parce que
je trouve ça susp vous êt un peu
populistes quoi les
sondages ils sont d'avant internet ils
sont d'avant internet en tout cas c'est
sûr moi je suis désespéré pour mes deux
amis je pense qu'ils ont des petits
soucis de santé et et des des troubles
auditifs parce que Jean-Jacques Goldman
c'est quand même l'homme des tubes qui
voilà qui il a marqué toute une
génération il y a encore des des jeunes
gens qui sont capables de chanter quand
la musique est bonne je marche seul
envoie-moi c'est une très belle chanson
un beau message qui un beau message pour
la lecture c'est pas tout à fait
français mais bonve mais mais est-ce que
l'artistique doit être français c'est le
message qui compte c'est
pas le contenant message mais oui il y a
un message il y a un message populaire
de de méritocratie et et moi je pense
qu'il faut le classer assez haut dans le
top 10 et ben vous savez ah dans le top
10 carrément alors jeanjac Goldman
évidemment pour l'instant il est premier
puisque c'est le seul on verra s'il
monte ou sil descend en tout cas il aura
occupé cette première place je suis pas
sûr avec les deux en face je suis pas
sûr que vous non non on va pas le tirer
toutes les toutes les 5 minutes Florent
bar le
suivant
suiv oui qui n'est pas dans cette liste
puisqu'il est belge Dominique A a ah bah
magnifique dominiica pour le coup voilà
pour moi le le plus grand un des plus
grands en activité qui a réinventé la
chanson française il y a maintenant 30
ans des disques d'une qualité constante
un grand parolier des textes à la fois
très littéraires et très touchants une
belle voix enfin voilà Dominica pour moi
c'est le c'est le chanteur français
idéal ouais pour moi c'est comme Monica
Bellucci c'est-à-dire que je connais le
nom mais je connais pas de film ou une
chanson de Dominique a donc je pourrais
pas me
prononcer c'est vrai non mais Olivier on
est bien d'accord Dominica formidable
mais à part quelques spécialistes comme
vous qui connaît Dominica non c'est pas
vrai il a reçu mais est-ce que c'est un
argument déjà mais oui c'est un argument
et on s le plus grand chanteur français
ce cas les plus gros les plus groses
vente et puis on non mais il faut quand
même que ces chanteurs français si on
les classe touche les gens que les gens
les connaissent on peut mettre ta
tailler aussi dans les dans les
chanteurs populaires si on veut bon ça
c'est une génération un peu ancienne
mais non dominiica il a reçu une
Victoire de la Musique en 2012 alors si
même les Victoires de la Musique s'y
intéressent ça veut dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui qui connaissent qu
nicolasem pour moi c'est un styliste un
vrai styliste il a inventé sa forme de
musique comme disait Olivier c'est aussi
un très bon parolier il fait pas de la
variété voilà donc quand on fait pas de
la variété on touche moins de monde h
c'est
mathématique pour moi il a sa place
ouais oui il a sa place mais devant ou
derrière jeanjcman devant bah pour moi
devant vous savez que jeman a aussi une
Victoire de la Musique oui oui un pe
Postume non non non 1986 victoire de
l'artiste interprte masculin vous mettez
donc oui mais je crois pour jeanjman
vous aurez du mal à le défendre bon
allez je vous fais plaisir Olivier NUC
parce que c'est vous le chef du du
service musique du Figaro flurent je
vais déclasser jeanjac Goldman Nicolas
allezy ti le nom suivant pendant que je
je j'effectue le classement que je vais
avoir moi
ah Michel Sardou ah non mais alors là on
laisse la parole à Florent bah oui bon
Michel Sardou c'est la dernière grande
star de la chanson française populaire
c'est près de 100 millions d'albums
c'est une quinzaine une vingtaine de
tubes c'est intergénérationnel chacun a
son Michel Sardou à sa chanson de Michel
Sardou sa Juliette Arman mais même
Juliette Arman je crois qu'elle aime
Michel Sardou au fond d'elle elle ne le
sait pas mais un jour elle va
l'apprendre et Michel Sardou c'est
l'homme des fins de soirée avec les lacs
du conéar ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit
un compliment pour faire monter dans le
classement l'homme l'homme des f soirée
c'est l'homme des f soirée c'est c'est
l'homme des chansons d'amour Makumba
allez h vous ne respectez rien c'est
l'homme des chansons d'amour c'est je
vais t'aimer c'est l'homme peut-être le
chanteur le plus courageux de la variété
française avec des chansons politisées
dans les années 70 il a su se renouveler
à chaque décennie c'est l'un des rares
artistes à avoir vendu un million
d'albums par décennie enfin un album qui
a dépassé le million d'exemplaires par
décennies jusqu'en 2004 voilà c'est
c'est Serge l a dit il a régné sur notre
métier et depuis 2004 justement que se
passe-t-il est-ce que Michel Sardou fait
pas partie de ces chanteurs qui jou les
prolongations 30 plus grands chanteurs
français de l'histoire à ce moment-là
freéel qui est dans les 50 qu'on a mis
en effet depuis des années non plus
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas pas
parce que sa carrière s'est arrêtée il y
a 20 ans justement s'est pas arrêté
s'était arrêté parce que là la dernière
tournée il annule une date sur trois
c'est un petit peu difficile
physiquement on est un petit peu la voix
est quand même endommagée ça a été un
très grand interprète vous juger
maintenant on essaie de juger sur
l'ensemble de l'ensemble de l'histoire
de la musique française parle
aujourd'hui en 2023 là on n'est pas en
78 il y a eu d'autres gens qui sont
apparus moi je pense qu'effectivement il
a sa place dans les grands chanteurs
français même si moi c'est pas du tout
la musique avec laquelle j'ai grandi
mais je reconnais
le talent d'interprète j'aime bien le le
le côté fort en gueule du bonhomme après
moi je suis allé voir des concerts on
sait pas les on s'éclate pas au concert
de Sardou hein c'est quand même ça reste
ça reste patrimonial avec tout ce que ça
a de bon et et de mauvais mais mais
laavouette patrimonial c'est peut-être
un bon argument pour rentrer dans le top
30 des plus grands chanteurs français
Olivier Nuuk peut-être mais je l'utilise
dans les deux sens
Nicolas euh moi le personnage m'est
sympathique euh je trouve enfin je suis
je suis content ant qu'il existe en fait
euhprs ça sa musique nous laisse de
marbre pour moi c'est la variété des
années 70 et Mar et Gilbert Carpentier
c'est tout ce que je vomissais quand
j'étais adolescent et que toujours pas
maintenant donc j'aime pas la variété et
c'est pas c'est pas du snobisme c'est
parce que je la trouve calibrée
prévisible souvent assez lisse vous êtes
là vousich Sardou n'est pas lisse c'est
vrai non non ça c'est vrai mais
musicalement c'est pas voilà moi ça me
ça me moi je vous le dis j'ai quand même
envie de le mettre auudessus de
Dominique Michel Sardou il y a pas de
débat B si justement il y a un débat on
est là il y a un déb mais il y a des
choses qui s'imposent aux gens Michel
Sardou s'impose à tout le monde oui
c'est vrai non mais on j'ai pas envie de
me faire insulter demain d'avoir mis
Michel Sardou après Dominica Olivier nu
voyez vousz de rien pe on peut on pe pe
miser sur Goldman nous les mais Goldman
il est à la retraite il est plus
chanteur du tout il mais ce n'est pas
oui on fait pas les 30 plus grands
chanteurs français du moment on fait les
30 plus grands chanteurs français de
l'histoire Olivier ah mais l'histoire
elle est en marche pas s'arrêter en 79
en bon dans ce cas moliè n'est plus
d'actualité et voyez et Mozart non plus
on les écoute plus ils sont desmés il
caé Mozard depuis 300 ans franchement
non mais là on parle de chanson
populaire une chanson qui c'est ça va
pas entrer dans l'histoire de la musique
soyons soyons raisonnable bah plus que
Dominica je pense que dans 30 ans on si
flottera des chansons de je 30 an mais
dans de siècles
siè voilà Mozard il a un peu plus de siè
alors là c'est toute la c'est toute la
musique en musique classique qui va
disparaî non il va rester les Beatles
oui pas bon euh c'est sûr Nicolas vous
êtes la voix de la raison est-ce qu'on
le met quand même auudessus de Dominica
pour vous faire plaisir ah bah voilà non
mais le problème de ce classement c'est
si sont les plus populaires qui arrivent
en haut
ENF joué d'avance on prend toutes les
listes des meilleures ventes et puis
d'accord mais on a mis Dominica devant
jean-jaces Goldman déjà oui ou alors
déjà oui mais on peut allez on continue
euh Olivier NUC le suivant alors ouais
qui peut-être une suivante d'ailleurs
parce que un non Gilbert becco Gilbert
becco alors un homme très très
sous-estimé en France parce qu'il a ce
tort en France on aime les paroliers et
les interprètes les compositeurs on les
reconnaît pas parce que on est quand
même dans un pays où les gens sont
complètement sourd sont incapables de
distinguer une mélodie grand compositeur
interprète cor tellement snob mais non
je musque d'accord on parle de musique
mais oui mais il y a des gens qui aiment
la musique sans forcément l'écouter
comme vous l'écoutez il y a des gens qui
aiment le vin sans pour autant le
connaître parfaitement ce que ce que je
suis en train de dire c'est qu'on
méprise les compositeurs on ne les
reconnaît pas dans ce pays parce qu'on
est un pays de lettre pour le meilleur
et pour le pire et qu'un mec comme becco
il y a aussi Julien claire ou chanft qui
sont très sous-estimés parce que ce sont
des mélodistes et Beco il a écrit au
moins un classique international qui est
letit bimi qui a été repris par Bob dyan
leseverly Brothers et plein d'autres et
pour ça il a notre respect éternel voilà
il y en a très peu en France qui ont
composé des standards
internationauxession vous allez être
d'accord là laiss par les Flor mais
Gilbert Beco totalement oublié mais
quelle discographie enfin mes mains
c'est une chanson absolument
exceptionnelle c'est un c'est pas un
tube justement parlait des tubes mais
mes mains c'est formidable et maintenant
c'est en septembre et C c'est en
septembre c'est un Chade qui a été
repris aussi par des chanteurs
anglosaxent repris par la star acadéie
c'est pas de la variété là non plus on
est dans la grande chanson française
dans la grande chanson française portée
par des beaux textes de Pierre deanoé la
musique de Gilbert becco et pour moi
c'est formidable il faut le redécouvrir
oui tout à fait d'accord Nicolas je
l'écoute rarement mais je suis d'accord
avec tout le monde mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il prend la première
place de classement g barbe là mais
pourquoi pas oui et ben voilà et ben qu
là vous me faites plaisir alors il
pourrait il pourrait être dégager du
classement juste pour désirer qui est
quand même une chanson affreuse quand il
a voulu se mettre à la mode c'est vrai
c'est affreuse mais bon son pass par
pour lui on a tous nos petits coup de
mou allez-y Florent client suivant si
j'ose dire ça serait bien qu'il a une
cliente quand même oui oui oui oui ah
ben Johnny àidé ah ou là épine ou là
flent vous avez la main ben moi je
défends encore la la chanson populaire
enfin Johnny on parlait de Michel Sardou
c'est le monstre sacré par excellence
qui a quand même fait découvrir et là je
vais faire hurler je pense Nicolas et
Olivier un peu le en France dans les
années 60 en adaptant pas mal de
standard euh mal très massacré avec des
textes indigens voilà mais il y a aussi
une partie de Johnny que moi j'aime
beaucoup qui est moins connu c'est la
période avec Philippe Labro avec les
textes JésusChrist est un hip il y a la
période aussi avec Jacques revau Gabriel
REM pour un fou moi je déteste la
période Goldman et Michel Berger parce
que je trouve que c'est pas Johnny mais
ça reste quand même le monstre et là ça
place dans le top 30 et après on verra
où on le place mais c'est quand même une
carrière exceptionelle quand même le
problème de fond avec Johnny idday c'est
que c'est un pur interprète et qu' ne va
rien rester parce que c'est pas un
auteur compositeur et qu'il n'y a pas
finalement c'est un homme qui a endossé
tous les costumes il a été Hipi il a été
punk il a été man max il a été chanteur
de variété il y a toujours cette cette
tentation dire qu'on navigue entre deux
eau il a fait des albums de grande
variété absolument inf
FME suivi toutes les modes il les a
suivi uniquement il les a jamais impulsé
jamais jamais
jamais jamais il il est pas dans des
plus grands chanteurs français de
l'histoire puis il y a des il y a le
petit retard d à la France où on prend
les choses à peu près 5 ans ou 10 ans
après les autres donc il a été il a été
hip en 79 par exemple non
malheureusement moi je j'ai pris du
plaisir à le voir sur scène parce que
c'était effectivement un interprète à
l'ancienne oui bien sûr non mais il
s'agit pas de mais c'est vrai que là on
est 6 ans après sa mort moi je pense
qu'il va rien rester parce que comme
l'intérêt c'était la scène Mo on m'
touours dit faut que voit sur scène je
suis allé le voir sur scène plusieurs
fois effectivement CIT une bête de scène
voilà avec une grosse voix avec des
codes un peu anciens c'était le Elvis
français on était vendu comme ça bon le
problème c'est qu' est-ce qu'on a envie
d'écouter le Elvis français longtemps le
temps de 2 heures dans concert oui après
che chez moi
etc bah moi il se trouve que j'adore
Elvis et que j'adore le rock donc je
peux pas aimer Johnny
ça paraît pas évident comme ça mais ouis
ouais c'est un AAT français de à peu
près tous les mouvements musicx qui ont
existé depuis
Elvis même fait une reprise de Creedence
avec des text de
d'ailleurs de personneou magnifique
ouais enfin l'original est mieux
toujours donc moi
non non allez vous le mettriez où là
dans dans C ces C là Olivier Goldman
audessus de Goldman audessus de Goldman
derrière Dominica et vous moi je
l'aurais mis devant Dominique a quand
même ouis et vous Nicolas audessus de
Goldman auessus dete la majorité
l'emporte importe vous savez que
j'aurais mon mot à dire à un moment un
autre ouou non mais pour l'instant je je
garde mes cartouche je choisis mes
combats allez-y Nicolas c'est à vous
vous avez pas choisi de nom depuis un
certain temps nous sommes toujours en
direct pour déterminer les 30 plus
grands chanteurs et chanteus il y a que
des hommes pour l'instant mais on attend
des femmes Daniel balav Daniel balavan
ah oui vous avez commencé par dire du
mal de lui il avit encore pas sorti
allez-y ah moi ça va être très simple
c'est l'atrocité
absolue atroce les paroles la vois la
musique les saintés des années 80 je
trouve ça ignob voilà j'en ai fini merci
moi je vais peut-être vous surprendre
mais je défendrai bal voire ah
euh pour un pour un tas de raisons c'est
c'est le c'est le premier concert que
j'ai vu mais ça c'est pas une raison moi
je vous dirais qu il est quand j'avais
dit pour moi pour moi si s'il avait s'il
était resté vivant je pense qu'il serait
plus grand que que Goldman ou
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un c'est
un meilleur parier peutêre un myth
autour de lui non je pense pas moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai qui disparaissent assez tôt
j'ai réécouté il y a 2 ans avec des
oreilles un peu fraîches parce que
j'écoute pas du tout cette musique là
chez moi non plus mais j'ai réécouté
pour pour un papier suite à un bouquin
que qu'on m'avait envoyé qui était très
bien et j'ai découvert des chansons très
bien et un artiste je pense qu'
qu'aurait fait des trucs il il était sur
le point d'aller monter un groupe de
rock à Londres quand il est mort je
pense qu'il aurait tourné le dos à à la
cette variété c'est vrai c'estes
productions un peu un peu on va dire
pompière non je pense que moi je lui
accorde le bénéfice du doute il est
quand même il est mort très jeune il a
je pense qu'il aurait fait des choses
surprenantes moi j'aime beaucoup sa voix
contrairement à Nicolas ouais euh
d'ESS Nicolas essayez montrez-nous ah
non je crois que vous êtes pas capable
donc la voix bon les textes c'est très
daté c'est très daté gauche des années
1980 voilà mais bon il a quand même sa
place parce que laaziza c'est un très
bon morceau SOS Nant chanson c'est le
chanteur la meilleure chanson sur le
métier de chanteur c'est celle-là je
vais faire des tubes et que ça tourne
bien Olivier Quand j'étais chanteur de
Michel Delpêche aussi oui aussi moi je
préfère celle-ci on le classe où selon
vous vous le mettriez où au-dessus de
Johnny audessus de Johnny ça ça vous
va descend
trs moi je crois que je préfère Johnny à
Balavoine par ah ouais donc on met
Balavoine après Johnny ALID pourquoi pas
allons-y Olivier nu je vous laisse tirer
le allez client suivant le chanteur ou
la chanteuse toujours pas de chanteuse
pour l'instant un petit jeune George
brassins ah George brassins allez
Nicolas vous avez pas souvent commencé
vous avez la main
euh bah brassin c'est un monstre
sacré qui vous insire pas BR non je suis
pas un fou de sa musique mais par contre
j'ai un immense respect pour le courage
pour sa musique pour ses ses textes pour
son côté un peu anard qui met qui m'est
très
sympathique ouais je pense c'est une
légende au même titre que brelle quoi
c'est euh
euh c'est c'est un c'est un monstre
sacré mais euh pour moi son son
son vous c'est pas un Mon Sacré pour sa
musique quoi c'est ça que vous me dites
si si si si si non non mais moi je bon
sa musique est un peu répétitive pour
moi ce qu'on appelle la pompe là à la
guitare mais euh mais c'est un c'est
c'est un véritable auteur quoi et et un
mélodiste avec des chansons beaucoup
plus Mo c'est toujours je me suis fait
tout petit devant une poupée qui est
inchantable non mais là le problème le
problème c'est qu'on tue le Game parce
que ça lui c'est c'est peut-être le plus
grand en France ah de tous les temps
mais c'est pas juste parce qu'on le
compare à des gens vivants en activité
mais brassin c'est le c'est le monument
moi je le mets bien au-dessus de brê euh
oui parce qu'il y a pas le Patos de BR
voà il y a pas le Patos ça a pas vieilli
parce que il y a pas de production c'est
très dépouillé c'est effectivement un
mec avec qui on a envie de de boire des
coups de manger des pâtes ou de de parce
que c'est une grande gueuleur si
possible oui c'est ça c'est une grande
gueule poétique les textes il y a
absolument rien enfin il y a rien
acheter chez brassin quoi c'est moi je
citerai Gaspar
prou ces textes sont très bien mais
c'est dommage qu'il chante parce que la
voix est quand même c'est toujs la même
chanson quoi ah non non peut pas dire ça
oui mais parce que toi tu aimes les les
fortes VO des arrangements
mais cette petite voix roulante là oui
c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression on peut
tous imiter BR et puis on fait ou mais
on peut pas tous écrire ces chansons on
peut pas par exemple Jack BR il a une
vraie interprte des
chans mais si c'est un parti prix c'est
de la chanson pépère un peu ah non c'est
pas vous me tout bien sû ou Nicolas pour
l'instant vu les autres oui je mettrai
numéro vous mettez devantber moi je le
mettra derrière Michel ah derrière
Michel Sardou
enore non mais je crois qu'on peut
trouver un équilibre il peut être entre
g et michardou
consulter non mais il peut être entre
Gilber et Michel SARD choqueaccepte
noniv
il est auudessus de B il est audessus de
tous pour moi voilà là voilà pour moi il
y a plus de débat après ça il y a plus
de débat après ça mais c'est non mais
c'est c'est d'accord avec avec ce que
dit Olivier d' c'est compliqué de mettre
brassins qui en plus est un pionnier
hein totalement il a inventé le métier
de je suis désolé mais ils m'ont
convaincu non puis j'ai vu j'ai vu la
voix est baissé chez Olivier Nuuk il a
pris beaucoup de profondeur et il m'a
convaincu il est en tête George brassin
pour l'instant Florent tirer le j'espè
je vais relever le niveau quand même
ouais mais vous avez réussi à placer
Michel Sardou en 3e position pour
l'instant c'était pas gagné avec nos
deux amis ah alors ça Booba ah ah mais
c'est pas de la chanson Booba moi je
connais que Booba de Chantal Goya ou le
gentil ourson oui je n'ai pas d'avis sur
ce monsieur Nicolas dehor
oui c'est pas de la chanson il n'a rien
à faire là d'accord il n'a rien à faire
là bon ben alors c'est très simple
euh mais luime je pense que lui-même
lui-même le REC Goldman quand même hein
non non non il est pour moi il n'a même
pas dans inquiétez pas il va finir par
sortir du classement on a encore
beaucoup mais pour l'stant je suis bien
obligé de mettre luiême je pense que
luiême ver classement dira je rien à
faire les raur maintenant veulent être
classé dans la
variette je pense pas non non les faux
rappeurs là oui qui quiont non non mais
je pense que c'est Nicolas allez-y
non mais
toiéour alors
Véronique Sanson ah Véronique Sanson
Laurent vous avez envie de parler
deonique S c'est l' toière en terme de
chanteuse c'est-à-dire que les textes
bon avant 1990 mais les années 70 c'est
formidable l'album Le modi enfin tout le
monde doit écouter le maudit c'est un
album extraordinaire pour moi voilà avec
peut-être François hardardi on fait pas
mieux dans la en terme de chanteuse il y
a il y a tous les styles romantiques
énergie
elle a même pris elle a pris des
positions aussi avec avec la chanson
c'est all je crois donc voilà pour moi
c'est c'est très moderne
encore
sticien pas toujours très bien
pass elle est totalement géniale elle a
inventé c'est la pour moi c'est la
personne on va pas dire femme ou homme
parce qu'on va pas faire de hiérarchie
c'est la musicienne en France qui a
inventé une nouvelle forme de de musique
c'estàdire qu'elle a vraiment intégré a
des génération qui a intégré les Beatles
la bossanova élargi le périmètre
euh les compos sont sont extra la
production parce que justement elle
enregistre à Los Angeles en 72 avec les
meilleurs musiciens du monde sous les
sous les conseil de stes mais elle a pas
besoin de lui pour briller c'est une
femme modeste qui a pas voulu une
carrière internationale alors qu'elle
aurait pu y prétendre pour moi après
après Barbara en France voilà c'est la
femme oui c'est c'est Nicolas
euh je suis d'accord avec Olivier bon
moi j'ai un peu de j'ai un peu de mal
avec son son trmolo parce que j'aime pas
le trémolo en fait mais de manière
générale he chez les hommes chez les
femmes voilàou euh mais c'est la seule
dont les les les 10 des années 70
puissent rivaliser avec les productions
anglosaxones King exactement euh donc
bon c'est pas j'écoute pas sa musique
vous
devriez j'ai quand même 6000 disques
chez moi donc j'ai des des trucs à
écouter ou mais euh mais je essay de
trouver vous en avez un des ronic Sanson
chez vous non mais il y en avait un chez
ma mre que j'avais offert à ma mère pour
une fête des mères il y a très longtemps
voyez mais euh bon on la classe où
Véronique s moi je pense non mais je
pense qu'il faut la classer haut parce
que je je
derèrere allez c'est magnifique il y a
un accord autour de Véronique Sanson
vous voyez qu'on y arrive mais oui
Olivier c'est pas vous bien sûr
je vous rappelle que nous essayons de
classer les plus grands chanteurs
français ah je sens que vous allez le
défendre oui j'ai écr un livre sur ce
monsieur il diain
d'anné livre sur Sardou c'est pour ça
qu' s BTU pour lui
je je vais pas me dédire je trouve que
voilà lui lui c'est c'est un cas d'école
justement c'est l'anti Johnny pour moi
c'est il a réussi là où Johnny raté
c'est qu'il a pris il a il a commencé en
66 dis avec des dis de variété infamme
parce que il avait 19 ans et que dans
France on reconnaissait pas le rock and
roll et il a réussi sur la longueur à
les à les dépasser tous avec des
paroliers extraordinaires Boris Bergman
dans la dans les premiers temps Gaby qui
est un tube extraordinaire vertige de
l'amour et une deuxième carrière ensuite
avec Jean Faou avec une dimension plus à
la léopéré plus grave que certains
préfèrent mais en tout cas il a été et
pour moi il continue d'être la une
statue du du Commandeur de la du rock en
France voilà c'est là non plus c'est je
pense pas que ce soit de la chanson
française c'est vraiment un rockur
Bachou et pour moi le plus grand rockur
français c'est lui ouais flurent non je
suis assez d'accord avec Olivier je en
plus je connais pas suffisamment toute
l'œuvre de Bachou mais les les 15 titres
que j'écoute je rejoins Olivier Nicolas
moi ce que j'apprécie chez lui c'est
qu'il a il a vraiment inventé son propre
univers quoi ça été long ça pas été
simple d'ailleurs moi je préfère la
période après après
Gaby fantaie militaire tout ça je j'ai
un peu un peu de mal avec les jeux de
mots systématiques de que ce soit ce
John F ou de Berman qui me fatigue un
petit peu quand
mêmegound ouais ouais ça ça me saoule un
peu mais après il a une belle voix et
puis il y a aussi la musique les
arrangements très ambitieux euh ouais
pour moi c'est l'un des plus grands
français alors où euh devant derrière
Gilbert BCO on est par là non on est
au-udessus oui auudessus Gilbert bec ou
ça vous embête de le mettre devant
Michel Sardou vous avez bien compris que
Michel Sardou va descendre moi je le
mettrai derrière Gilbert becco mais
Gilber parce que Olivier a utilisé
l'argument Massu Gilbert becco est l'un
des rares qui a fait un standard
international ah ouais ouais ça vous va
derrière Gilbert B ouais ouais vous AZ
pas l'air emballé
oui non mais bon c'est les classement ce
classementement contre il est contre cl
je cro que vous allez dire un gros mot à
propos de ce classement non non mais oui
bon derrière BO oui parce que B oui puis
en plus
B avant là c'est pas du tout déshonorant
là non là pour l'enstant ça vous
convient
oui oui oui bon allez Florent on
continue Charles traîner ah là c'est
pareil traîner allez-y Florent pour moi
Charles traîner c'est mieux que brassins
mais en terme
d'interprétation les textes sont sont
formidables la musique elle a certains
titres ont quand même très très mal
vieillli mais d'autres restent très
puissant et on parlait de standards
internationaux la mer euh voilà qui a
été repris par les plus grands donc
ouais c'est un super artiste encore un
qui est oublié malgré quelques reprises
d'Ant que ça il est pasou il est quand
même euh si on parler avec Stéphan
hofmanance oui dou France mais il y a
d'autres titres comme que resto- de nos
amours et cetera qui sont ont un peu
disparu qui mérite de nos amours de mes
amours je on en parle aprè comme Antoine
de C enfin il y a vraiment des
inconditionnels mais auprès de la jeune
génération je suis ah bah la jeune
génération elle oublie tout hein en ça y
est
pas non mais je suis pas sûr que les
jeunes de 15 ans écoutent Goldman par
exemple non je pense que c'est
certainement pas ouais en class non mais
le le là on est comme c'est comme rassin
voilà c'est c'est c'est un des un des
type qui a inventé la chanson française
telle qu'on la connaît c'est et lui en
la matinant au jazz c'est extrêmement
moderne traîn quand il arrive c'est
c'est une révolution totale à la fois
dans la le le le les place le placement
des mots c'est que ça swing ça swingit
pas la chanson française jusqu'à lui le
le le le sens des mots après le
personnage est moins sympathique que que
brassin c'est c'est à mon avis ce qu'il
dessert c'est que c'est un personnage
moins sympatiqueou c'est V vous avez
raison moi je le mettrai juste derrière
brassin moi juste au-dessus ou enfin
dessus ou en dessous donc derrière
brassin et moi je mettrais en dessous de
Véronique Sanson ouais c'est Véronique
Sanson tout le monde a parce que pour
moi elle est elle est elle est moins
datée qu
oui ah c'est vrai allez vous me
convainquez par cet argument elle est
moins morte surtout elle est moinste
elle a pas fait de tube depuis 30 ans ou
on continue for il faut qu'on accélère
un peu parce que sinon Nicolas si alors
moi j'aime beaucoup tous ces débats si
on est tous d'accord plus ou moins on
accélère qui vous avez tiré Bernard
laviler allez-y moi ça me
saoule c'était Laurent chalumo qui dans
Ken folk l'avait décrit en disant le
grand faazone enchaîné à son
Dictionnaire de
RIM pour moi c'est vraiment le type qui
a trop lu corortomaltaz et qui bon après
je comprends il a son univers qui peut
fasciner les gens l'Amérique du Sud
l'aventurier le baroudeur mais moi ça
me moi je vais le défendre parce que moi
je c'est un type qui m'a qui m'a déplu
pendant des années je trouve que depuis
15 ans il a une espèce de de revitalité
ça se dit pas mais de de de ENF il y a
quand même de très grande chanson c'est
un mec droit dans ses bottes je pense
que c'est un grand mythoman aussi mais
ça ça fait partie du personnage des
anecdotes ou mais que je mais qui qui
est un bon interprète qui un un mec qui
écrit bien voilà c'est pas c'est pas un
inventeur mais c'est c'est c'est une
figure c'est une figure importante oui
je suis assez d'accord et deux chansons
les mains d'or et idé noir qui est une
chanson absolument fabuleuse on met où
Bernard lavid on le met vers Dominica
après lui c'est Balavoine en mieux non
non c'est pas pareil oui mais 10e ce
serait bien 10e viler 10e 10 allez pour
10e pour l'instantin vous savez que ce
classement va évoluer on continue
allez-y qui doit
tirer pour l'instant jeens que ce
classement vous déplais pas Olivier je
vous senteaz
C je vais reprendre la même
argumentation que pour B très
sous-estimé parce que il a jamais écrit
ses textes mais il a composé toutes les
musiques et réécouter chasseur
d'ivoir c'est r 20 ans avant
r la production les c'est un c'est un
grand c'était un grand pianiste qui a
des suites d'accords quand même assez
renversante jeune mot compris c'est pas
un grand interprète c'est vrai que c'est
un peu le parent pauvre de l'équation
champfort mais euh il a quand même eu
c'est un des seuls hommes à avoir
travaillé justement il a ce point commun
avec Bachou ils ont tous les deux
travaillé avec ginsbourg qui ne
travaillent qu'avec des femmes donc
quand même pour avoir l'estime et la
collaboration de de ginsbourg c'est que
ginzbourg l'admirait même s'il était
évidemment vachard parce que jaloux et
cetera mais non grand grand artiste très
sous-estimé qui doit revenir cette année
d'ailleurs chanfort Nicolas euh il m'est
sympathique euh un peu pour les sans
plus voilà euh moi je suis un grand fan
de de je sens qu'on a un fan oui euh ça
avait mal commencé puisquil était
chanteur à à minette avec Claude
François non il a commencé pianiste de
oui mais il a il a il a commencé sa
carrière de chanteur ouis ah oui c'était
pas terrible c'était bah c'était du sous
claud François ouis et il a pris son
envol à la fin des années 70 et c'est
lui qui a fait Manu Reva non oui bien sr
c'est horrible ça c'est pas sa meilleure
mais mais c'est la plus connue amour
amour année zé c'est un album
extraordinaire tendre fièvre c'est
fabuleux et même dans les années 90 où
il a eu moins de succès il y a quand
même des des petites pépitesemi dans la
glace c'est une très belle chans est-
que ça vous si on le met juste après
Michel Sardou devant très sympathique en
plus très très il aime beaucoup la
musique il il s'intéresse je lui ai fait
découvrir Amy wi house il y a 15 ans et
c'était vraiment enthousiasmé il en
parlait partout voilà c'est un c'est un
vrai amourux de musique c'est un vrai
musicien allez on continue Alain
champfort qui arrive assez haut dans ce
classement euh ah B alors là oui je je
je vois le nom que vous avez dit Michel
paulnarf Michel paulnarf Michel
paulnareev c'est le plus anglosaxon de
nos chanteurs c'est celui qui a réussi à
faire qu'à popiser les paroles
françaises c'estd que tout le début de
sa carrière c'est il y a je pense qu'il
n'y a rien acheté jusqu'en gros à l'êre
à France où il commence à se caricaturer
mais sinon c'est éblouissant enfin il
faut écouter les les premières chansons
amkalin love me please love me Gloria et
ceera sous quelle étoile suis je NIS
sous quelle étoile suis-je né et c'est
extraordinaire toute la le début de
carrière est formidable après c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que c'est
l'éternel retours on peut faire et puis
on peut on peut avoir le même reproche
que qu'avec Jean-Jacques Goldman il fait
quoi depuis des années ben c'est
l'éternel retour non il lui il revient
alors que Goldman revient pas du tout il
arrive plus du tout à
nonve il a il a ce point commun avec
avec du Tron il a ce point commun avec
du Tron c'est qu'il vivent sur 15
chansons géniales et que ça s'est arrêté
complètement effectivement quelque part
en 74 75 après pour chez Paul NF il
convient quand même de séparer l'homme
de l'artiste c'est je dis c'est
important c'est quand même un un drôle
de mec c'est un peu un escrro moi je
suis allé voir la tournée l'année
dernière je suis allé voir la première
date de la tournée il avait pas répété
pas joué avec les musiciens j'ai assisté
à une répétition moi c'est pas grave je
paye pas mes places c'est mon métier
mais il y a des fans qui payaient leur
place et qu'on assist à une répétition
c'était à Nice c'était le soir de la
mort de Tina Turner et franchement c'est
une
escroquerie et je trouve que les retours
orchestré sans nouvelles chansons depuis
des années il avait composé un album qui
était pas si mauvais il y a quelques
années qui a été jeté partout mais il y
avait des choses assez audacieuse
dessus après c'est pour moi c'est comme
un chanteur disparu voyez je pense
qu'effectivement 66 6 75 c'est une
perfection et c'est c'est c'est c'est le
Brian Wilson français c'est un inventeur
de génie aussi Nicolas euh 76 75
entièrement d'accord en plus c'est quand
même une musique assez ambitieuse c'est
pas du trois accords de base en deors de
la poupée qui qui fait non qui est très
très simple qui mil ouais mais mais oui
c'est une musique exigeante et
ambitieuse donc même si sa carrière
s'est arrêté enfin artistiquement
parlant s'est arrêté assez rapidement
bon il a il a incontestablement sa place
exigeant et populaire à la fois ce qui
est quand même pas cour Michel Paul narf
on le met où allez si vous deviez me
donner un un chiffre en qure devant
Gilbert becco ça ça vous convient ça oui
oui et vous
Nicolas euh
oui en 4 ou en 5 enfinoule pour le bal
desaz ça mérite CHV ou là pu on avait
travaillé pour le balzaz on sens que
c'est pas une petite musique comme vous
dites c'est pas BR ah non brassin c'est
très composé non non ça je pas oui oui
oui c'est très il y a aussi la musique
de la folie des grandeurs incroyable qui
doit tirer le prochain nom nous en
sommes au 15e il va falloir accélérer
monessieur vous parlez vous parlez alors
je vais lire quand même ce qu'on nous
dit on nous parle beaucoup de Léo feré
mais on l'a pas encore tiré Jean-Louis
Murat ah que faire de Jean-Louis Murat
ça c'est un nom eu met en trois
directement alors moi respect total pour
Mura
euh pour même si j'écoute très très
rarement sa musique mais quand je
l'écoute j'y prends beaucoup de plaisir
j'aime l'homme j'aime sa franchise son
intelligence et j'aime son courage parce
qu'il a fait une musique assez
courageuse dans qui qui rentre pas dans
le moule habituel donc voilà comme il
faut aller vite je viens de m'exprimer
moi j'ai rien ajouté proche de
Jean-Louis mur oui mais j'étais j'aimais
sa musique avant d'être proche de lui
moi j'ajouterai rien et je dir je
reprendrai mot pour mot ce qu' dit
Nicolas et moi je connais pas assez donc
je c'est ça le problème mais oui mais
c'est un argument est-ce qu'il peut être
aussi haut que Gilbert Michel et Charles
tra voyez c'est pas la question de la
poitvidmentors estce qu'il était plus
talentueux que mais dans ce cas on peut
mettre Carlos aussi il vendu plus de
disur mais pas écr d'I Bonn chance non
alors on met
oùme 3è 3è
3èux pe pas mettre devant Paul c'est
pas moi je le mettrais euh c'est vous
qui allez tranch soyez soyez non mais
bon je veux pas me fâcher avec Olivier
mais moi moi je le mettrais un peu
au-dessus de Bachou parce que je pense
c'est un peu peu la même génération et
puis ils ont chacun leur propre univers
bon voilà allez on a trouvé un juste
milieu avec avec Jean-Louis Murat ça
vous va Olivier
oui oui bon allez on continue on Contin
continu dans ce dans ce classement 15 N
ont déjà été tirés Booba jeanjacman ne
devrait pas faire long feu dans ce
classement des 30 dev assez vite sortir
allez on continue je je lis ce que nous
disent les les internautes et Barbara
Barbara aussi elle arrive Souchon arrive
Piaf brelle point d'interrogation vous
inquiétez pas Naro nouaro nouaro alors
je je dirais juste c'est comme
B oublié injustement oublié il y a eu
des disques épouvantables moi j'ai
grandi à la pire époque parce que
c'était nouayor qui est horrible ça
c'est quand même ça c'est l'infamie
total je croyais que c'était son son
grand ou c'est sa résurrection 10 années
60 je dois dire moi j'ai découvert sur
le tard à la faveur de de recevoir une
intégrale et les 10 années 60 et ce
qu'il a fait en particulier avec le jazz
et la musique brésilienne c'est assez
poustouflant très grand interprète très
grand
parolier personnage un peu fatigant mais
le petit taureau on l'app ouais mais
grande figure un peu usant un peu
systématique disons oua je comprend mais
mais mais quelques très très grands
disques oui quand même un grand alors
moi j'avais un un un père qui était un
fanatique de jazz et on était amis avec
des musiciens de jazz dont l'organiste
Eddie luwiis eddys donc Edy il venait
chez nous on allait chez lui il a joué
sur les donc c'était le quasiment les
seuls disques français qui passait à la
maison était ceux de nouaro et bon moi
j'aime pas du tout je suis les disques
nougayor pour moi c'est une infamie mais
pour ce qu'il a fait pour le jazz et la
musique et la musique brésilienneut so
des trucs comme locomotive d'or par
c'est mag magnifique donc oui oui il a
sa place ouais ouais je suis d'accord
enfin c'est comme B un peu oublié il
faut le redécouvrir et typiquement quand
on parle d'interprétation lui interprète
vraiment ses chansonsou ou oui paril
vous parz de brê tout à l'heure sil
mettait son corps qui transpirit non
puis il a pris des standards de jazz
qu'il a vraiment totalement la chanson
sur la boxe elle est incroyable mais
dans c'est sur moi qure boules de cuir
bien sûr on le met où audessus d'Alain
Bachou au-dessus de Jean-Louis Murat der
B je juste derrière Bach devant Michel
Sardou Michel Sardou qui descend il
reste il reste il
s'accroche s sort du top 30 ce sera
quand même difficile allez allez-y
Florent c'est à vous pour le prochain
nom on passe voyz sur cette deuxème
colonne fre ah frelle tiens Nicolas vous
avez envie d' parler ce sera Nicolas qui
parlera moi j'aime bien c ces
chant j'avais reçu dans les années 90
parce que j'étais journaliste de musique
j'avais reçu une tonne de CD de de Ch et
chanteuse de cette époque que j'ai j'ai
j'ai j'ai gardé que j'écoute rarement il
faut le dire oui c'est ça parce que vous
dites j'écoute jamais ça c'estum depuis
le déboute pas vous écoute pas fritelle
évidemment on va pas la mettre numéro 1
quoi mais mais elle a eu son importance
cette chanson
réaliste il y a de la poésie en même
temps làdedans quoi bon voilà après
c'est sûr que ça en 2023 je suis pas sûr
que tout le monde puisse écouter frè
ouais c'est un peu mal
viilliig c'est une figure importante
effectivement d'un mouvement qui a été
très important et c'était une star de
son époque et c'est une femme qui a
influencé c'est gansbourg qui avait dit
qui qu'il l'avait croisé quand il était
petit garçon et qu'elle l'avait
encouragé ouais en disantce c'était
c'était une femme assez transgressive
oui quand même c'était c'est une grande
figure est-ce qu'on la mettrait pas
juste après Johnny
ALID ça a l'air de vous laisser
sceptique ou non ouais pourquoi pas ou
ou allez derrière manière quand on va
tomber sur Piaf oui voilà ouais on va
tomber sur PF oui on va tomber sur PF
allez-y peut-être maintenant Nicolas et
on avance dans ce classement George
brassins domine toujours notre TOP 30
des plus grands chanteurs français
devant Véronique Sanson et Charles
trînet Eddie Mitchell Eddie Mitchell
allez-y Florence vous vous ai vu vousi
une passion pour Eddie Mitchell oui vous
êtes seul peut-être c'est mieux pour moi
c'est mieux que Johnny alors il y a
moins de tube ah ben oui mais il y a il
y a une sensibilité il y a des très
beaux textes il ne rentre pas ce soir
c'est formidable chanson couleur les
yeux couleur Mentalo c'est formidable
cimetière des éléphants cimetière des
éléphants il y a quelque chose chez lui
autant le début de carrière un peu
insupportable c'est un peu du c'est
comme Johnny quoi c'est du
yer ce qu'il a sauvé c'est
qu'effectivement il sait écrire voilà il
sait écrire et à un moment c'est
lui-même qui m'a expliqué dit moi je
recevais des des traductions ineptes de
standard américain je me suis dit je
peux je peux faire au moins aussi bienor
fallait y aller quand même he voilà et
il a quand même pour moi sur la route de
Memphis c'est une chanson qui est
meilleure en français que l'original
américain le texte est meilleur il y a
l'humour après il y avait quand même il
avait papa diamand 10 pour ses pour ses
compositions donc un mélodiste
exceptionnel un bon
interprète très belle carrière moi c'est
vrai que moi c'est c'est c'est mon
enfance pour le coup c'est ma mère qui
écoutait beaucoup Michel et je suis
content de jusqu'à l'b blues je dirais
c'est c'est un sans faute et puis il a
parlé un peu de l'époque enfin il ne
rentre pas ce so meilleur adaptateur de
chuckberry aussi en France la dernière
séance qui est quand même une chanson
sur les cinémas qui qui disparaissent
non non moi je je connais pas très bien
en fait euh non je suis pas je suis pas
un fou ce que enfin ce que je connais
c'est souvent mais c'est peut-être pas
les meilleurs disques hein euh c'est
souvent de la de la de la country moins
bonne que la country américaine je
trouve après il enregistrit tous ses
disques à nasheville avec les musiciens
de là-bas il a quand même le sonou mais
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est pas euh c'est pas wellon Jennings
quoi non bien sû voilà euh mais euh bon
euh non non mais il a sa place
regarde sur notre
classement moi je le mettrai juste
devant Johnny ah juste devant ou son un
joli symbole vous allez mettre du Tron
par là aussi vous allez peut-être vous
battre un peu plus pour du Tron non on
continue du Tron c'est c'est pas si
simple que ça c'est moi là oui c'est à
VOUS Olivier alors ah bah là ça va
friter là Benjamin Biolet ah oui je
crois que ça va friter allez-y vous avez
la main moi je défends Benjamin parce
que mais déjà vous l'appelez par son
prénom non mais c'est pour aller vite
non c'est pour aller vite je
violet parce que parce que je trouve que
de moi je qui qui est cette personne
parce que sa génération c'est celui qui
domine à mon avis bon c'est plus un
jeune il a 50 ans on est encore jeune à
50 ans n'est-ce pas mais non c'est un
c'est surtout parce que c'est un
musicien d'abord et avant tout c'estd il
a quand même beaucoup écrit pour les
autres plutôt enfin oui mais c'est pas
il a fait beaucoup d'albums il a fait
beaucoup il est très productif non il
domine est-ce que c'est un musicien
avant tout Mo domine une génération qui
qui est très faible donc c'est toujours
pareil ça c'est vous ça c'est votre
responsabilité de le dire c'est pas la
mienou c'est vrai
euh non je trouve que c'est un musicien
c'est un musicien d'abord non mais là on
parle de lui je cyais qu'on avait pas le
temps donc on va V vous énervez pas je
m'énerve pas mais les classements
çaattend toujours un
peu non mais il a sa place il il a il a
sa place oui c'est pour ça qu'il est
dans les 50 est-ce qu'il a sa place dans
les 30 vous le mettriez où oui dans les
30 ouais il a je le mettrai je le
mettrai où
[Musique]
euh réfléchissez FL Baro vous en pensez
quoi derrière Dominica derrière Dominica
ouais c'est un peu comme ginbourg mais
il a pas réussi à passer le step de de
devenir un interprète à part entière là
il a rempli Bercy quand même il y a 10
jours c'est là pour le coup il est
populaire quand on joue à berc c'est
vrai qu'il il a son public mais c'estàd
qu'il est devant Johnny ALID moi je le
mettrai en dessous de Johnny mais bon je
êre encore non non mais non Nicolas vous
en pensez quoi
euh c'est c'est un vrai musicien je suis
entièrement d'accord euh en plus qui est
capable de faire des choses assez
variées ouais euh donc il est pas dans
un registre il est pas limité après bon
euh l'homme a tendance à m'exaspérer
mais euh après tout c'est
pas voulez vous voulez le mettre vous
êtes la la voix de la raison vous le
mettez avant
Johnny ah ça vous fait mal au cœur de
mettre Benjamin Biolet devant Johnny
ALID je le sais même si Olivier nux se
battra pour
euh non moi je le mettrai après Johnny
quand même parce que pour parce que non
là c'est moi qui vais faire du populisme
quoi c'estàdire que vraiment Biolet
c'est V un public de bobo téérama et
cetera bon t Tama non je travaille ici
he Le Figaro l'a toujours beaucoup
défendu d'ailleurs c'est pire que la CMP
en fait ce classement oui c'est vrai moi
jeis fait un article qui s'appelait le
chian des partisans
s trs parce qu' il a repris il avait
peur que le FN arrive et CEA donc on
continue allez-y oh là là c'est un gros
morceau ça william Scheller william
Scheller ah oui là parlerit des
compositeurs auteur compositeur
interprète euh je pense que lui il est
pas oublié parce qu'il y a une chanson
qui sort du L me alors c'est vrai
qu'elle a jamais été enregistré elle est
enregistré qu' studio c'est vrai cette
ch un concert en je dire c'est pour moi
c'est formidable et c'est tout le temps
formidable c'est-à-dire que le chellerer
qui s'est transformé des années
70 aux années 2000 c'est pas le même
chellerer mais c'est toujours hyper
agréable à écouter les compositions sont
soignées les textes sont beaux c'est
pour moi c'est un des
monuments c'est une carrière une
carrière complètement
exemplaire très varié il a fait des dis
de rock and roll à Londres par qu'en
fait c'est un homme qui vient du
classique é perc par les Beatles et qui
qui a conjugué les deux qui n' cessé de
d'essayer de conjuguer les deux et avec
beaucoup de réussite même les tubes
populaires sont toujours très dignes
très élégants très bien composé c'est
très chiadé c'est très difficile à
chanter il est il aime pas écrire mais
c'est un très bon parolier c'est
évidemment un un interprète enfin c'est
un géant pour moi c'est un géant très
très très sous-estimé encore une fois
William chut pe le mettre ass dans ce
classement tous les jeunes lui lui lui
doivent quelque chose il y a un album
homage qui est sorti à quelques mois
vrai un peu comme on fait Goldman
d'ailleurs oui mais il est vivant il il
est à la retraite lui aussi il a décidé
d'arrêter de d'écrire et de chanter il
fait de la musique instrumentale non non
c'est un c'est un un très grand dans un
pays de de O on est un peu nain où on
est un peu nain sur le plan musical moi
je connais pas très bien mais euh j'aime
beaucoup ce que je connais ouais c'est
bien voilà mais ça c'est et et encore
une fois là je me répète mais bon non
seulement c'est de de toute évidence un
itable musicien mais aussi je trouve
assez audacieux assez courageux dans
dans ses choix et ça j'apprécie on le
met où on le met très très je mettrai
derrière ou devant B
oui oui oui je derrière Paul Nar moi je
trouve c'est pas
mal allez bien voilà vous êtes d'accord
enfin vous l'avez placé en une seconde
on continue Nicolas c'est à vous de
tirer le prochain nom on a peu de femmes
pour l'instant mais on en a mis quand
même dans cette dans cette list
évidemment oui fr fr alors bah là
Barbara ah voà justement allez-y vous
avez la main Nicolas euh je suis pas
ultra sensible à la musique de Barbara
qui a un peu tendance à me
déprimer non mais je suis capable de je
suis capable d'écouter des musiques
beaucoup plus déprimantes comme les
albums solo de Nico par exemple bon euh
mais je vois pas comment on peut comment
on ne peut pas la placer très très haut
quoi c'est vraiment
elle
est elle est unique quoi voilà il y a
pas de a il y a pas de copie de Barbara
c'est impossible c'est c'est amusant en
plus que qu'elle sorte juste après
william Scheller parce que c'est elle
qui a encouragé William chellerer a
chané ça a quand même été une
inspiration et une femme inspirée
jusqu'au bout c'est elle est totalement
unique oui je reprends l'argument de
Nicolas dans le monde entier il y a pas
deux Barbara et elle a fait avancer la
chanson d'une manière incroyable FL non
mais je suis assez d'accord bon moi
j'écoute pas ça tous les jours parce que
je tiens à être quand même avoir le
moral mais après une rupture c'est bien
préfère tirli pimpon sur le Chiha ah je
préfère tirli pimpon sur le chihuahua ou
tatayoyo mais non non mais c'est vrai
que les textes la musique c'est
nantting enfin non puis elle elle est
vraiment habitée quoi enfin c'est c'est
c'est une chanteuse ah oui oui supérieur
on la met où je trouve que en plus elle
est numéro 2 non moi j'aurais mis devant
Véronique Sanson moi j'aurais peut-être
mis après traîner mais ah on est on est
par ici Nicolas la 3è place ouais après
après traîner ouais après tra ça me va
bien est-ce que ça vous va quand même
sur la M aprèstaîner ou vous vous tenez
à ce qu'elle soit avant traîné moi je la
mettrai avant traîner allez voilà comme
ça on se met donc à proximité de vonic
Sanson voilà c'est très bien vous voyez
il y a pas beaucoup de femmes mais elles
occupent le le haut du classement
Olivier on continue George brassins
Véronique Sanson Barbara un classement
qui évolue qui pourra déc George brassin
Dalida magnifique vient de me dire
Florent baraco dans l'oreil gauche non
mais ça je sais que mes amis vont dire
que c'est trop populaire pour moi ça ça
n'existe pas voilà
c'est-à-dire ça existe on s'en fiche que
ce soit populaire on adore les Beatles
les Beatles onendu des millions des
milli non mais d'accord mais Dalida a
marqué quand même une partie
de de la France elle est encore très
pour moi c'est je reprends l'argument de
Nicolas tout c'est les émissions des
carpentiers des années 70 c'est le
showbiz les paillettes à la
française mais quand on parlait de
Michel Sardou et les fins de soirée
mourir sur scène ça passe dans tous les
bases tout le temps préfecture mooi
danser oh non c'est pas pré répond
répond non mais c'est c'est un peu du
snobisme oui je suisc mais non mais on
dès qu'on aaime pas quelque chose qui
est populaire on est snob non mais c'est
un pe diva de souspréfecture c'est un
peu du snobisme elle chante quand même
elle ch alors le problème c'est qu'elle
écrit pas ses
textes c'est pas la seule dans ce
classement elle danse mal elle non moi
moi j'étais enfant j'avais peur quand
elle passait à la télé j'avais peur je
pensais que c'était elle elle rououle en
plus qu c'est affreux c'est affreux
c'est un cauchemar venez d'avoir 18 ans
c'est une super chanson incroyable Ji
pas qu'Al se vend Gigi la mororoso
incroable oui Gigi laamoroso c'est c'est
ringar c' déjà ringar en
82 enfin franchement parole parole elle
quand même mieux en français qu'en
italien non
c'estable façon là je pourrais pas
lutter hein protégeons la jeunesse
protégeons la jeunesse vous Nicolas euh
moi comme ou pour moi dehors elle a pas
sa place par devant Booba quand même non
mais Booba on va se débrouiller pour qu'
dégage a B il va y aller tout seul heina
ouais c'est non mais en queue de
classement ouais en queue de classement
non alors vous vous vous le mettriez où
vous la derrière Boba derrière Booba oui
non Booba il me fait Booba me fait rire
ah oui c'est déjà pas mal ah oui elle
vous fait pas rire du tout vous
Nicolas euh moiaboua me fait pas rire et
Dalida non plus bon donc vous mettrez
juste devant et vous Florent non mais
fait moi je non mais moi je l'aurait mis
derrière Bernard Lavillier allez on peut
se mettre d'accord là-dessus est-ce
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord là-dessus
toute façon elle va sortir oui elle va
sortir du classement là on a bien
compris j'espère qu'Orlando ne regarde
pas cette émission V c'est vraiment pas
grandchose he dalid fa ah non moi je
pour moi c'est rien c'est rien non mais
c'est vraiment non mais après un avis
tranché vaut un avis et il a très bien
défendu contrairement à vous vous êtes
un peu effendra Florent sur cette
histoire je trouve allez-y parce que je
pense que je ne crois même pas à ma
défense on continue ah Etienne Dao
Etienne Dao ti Nicolas comment c'est euh
il m'est très sympathique parce que tout
le monde tout le monde vous ass il pas
pas r ça et souvent il y a une petite
pique il y aura pas de pique moi je je
je suis pas un fanatique de la musique
de DAO mais par contre il a eu une belle
carrière parce qu'il a il s'est
renouvelé très régulièrement il a même
s'il a fait un moment de la pop qui a
touché un immense public he il y a eu la
DAO Mania dans les années 80 euh mais il
a jamais fait de variété quoi avec des
des vilains
Sainté des moches batterie enfin il a il
a ouais puis son parcours est exemplaire
en fait son parcours est exemplaire
parce qu'à chaque fois il essaie de se
remettre en question et d'aller de
l'avant donc ça c'est admirable voilà
vous avz l'air d'accord pour moi c'est
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est le patron oui
c'est effectivement c'est un exemple de
parce qu'on a tous on a tous pensé que
qu'il allait pas survivre aux années 80
et il a eu la l'intelligence et la
ressource et le talent de proposer des
choses la rupture c'est c'est l'album
Eden en 96
personnel introspectif qui est l'un de
ses favoris d'ailleurs qui est l'un de
ses préférés parce qu' il se dévoile
beaucoup et en même temps il signe en
c'est la deuxème partie de carrière qui
est exemplaire la première partie de
carrière c'est c'est un c'est un jeune
homme il est beau il est chic il a des
tubes mais ça il y en avait plein mais
lui il a fait la différence sur le long
terme je suis allé voir son show là il
va être il va être àé dans quelques
jours le show il y a quand même des
tubes des tubes et des tubes moi ça
c'est c'est quand même un répertoire qui
a rythmé nos vies depuis l'école c'est
il y a aussi des morceaux qui sont pas
d'é tues mais qui sont très intéressants
ah oui oui puis il a eu l'audace il
avait chanté Jeunet avec Jean Morau moi
je les avais vu à l'Odéon il faut quand
même avoir du du courage ah vous êtes
d'accord mais alors on le met où très
haut trèsut très TR auudessus de bah
vers d'cord pour une fois ouais mais moi
j'aime par exemple moi j'aime je préfère
la première partie de carrière ouais qui
est bien aussi mais bon alors on met où
moi je mettrai vers cheller ou B oui oui
oui carrément oui ouis ah entre les deux
ouais ouais ouais moi ça me va entre les
deux allez tine da qui remonte qui monte
asse haut dans ce classement je rassure
ceux qui nous regardent alors déjà
Johnny ALID 15e n'importe quoi c'est ce
qu'on dit oui regardez où ils ont mis
Johnny sérieux non ben oui regardez
regardez vous vous avez pas honte
franchement on dit mais où sont ginbour
et Christophe vous inquiétez pas ils
arrivent nous avons encore à peu près 20
noms à sortir on continue c'est Nicolas
qui doit tirer le prochain le prochain
chanteur prochaine chanteuse de ce top
30 nous essayons de oui Patrick Brel ah
Patrick BR alors figurez-vous c'est moi
moi c'est mon premier concert avec mes
parents j'aime beaucoup patri BR
allez-y ils vont être méchants ou s
méchant tu tuas des mauvais résultats à
l'école ils ont
V non moi je à la ptin d'alberv
formidable non je je c'est c'est un
c'est un type qui qui est sur deux
jambes depuis 40
ans la chanson
et et et voilà il a une popularité moi
c'est c'est pas ma musique l'homme m'est
sympathique vraiment c'est un c'est un
ambitieux qu'on veut qui s'est donné les
moyens qui s'est accroché après je pas
sensible à sa musique mais je le trouve
investi dans ce qu'il fait moi j'aime
beaucoup Patrick Brel alors moins fan de
la Bruel Mania mais typiquement il a su
réinventé ave Pat comme
ça mais alors typiquement dans la Bruel
Mania il y a place des grands hommes qui
est quand même un hymne partagé par
plein de générations on a tous rêvé de
se retrouver 10 ans après mais moi
j'aime bien inventé copain d'avant en
fait il a inventé copain d'avente ex
c'est tout à fait exact et la deuxième
partie de carrière moi je trouve elle
est hyper intéressante il y a un album
qui s'appelle juste avant qui est
formidable il y a un album après où il
écrit avec des chansons avec Amanda STS
qui sont je fais semblant qui est une
chanson absolument sublime et je trouve
c'est une carrière une carrière sans
faute c'est-à-dire que c'est pas c'est
pas
c'est pas Gilbert B mais ça commence
avec Mar de cette nana là quand même oui
ça commence mal mais terrible mais c'est
pas d'Alida et c'est pas jean-jac
Goldman quoi je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose chez Bruel une sensibilité et il
nous il arrive à nous parler vous êtes
en train de me convaincre allez-y bon
moi je peux
pas je peux pas si si je syp je peux non
même pas ENF il m pas antipathique il
sait rien quoi mais j'aime bien Brel
quand il est quand il est imité par
l'uréral j'aime beaucoup oui vous voulez
essayez je TR non j'ai pas les talents
de de G mais là je trouve ça très bon on
est vous avez la main Florent ou chois
moi je le mettrais euh je le mettrais
euh au-dessus de Dominique A au-dessus
de Dominique A oh non bon vous savez ce
qu'on va faire on va mettre juste en
dessous allez mais vous avez vu comme il
l'a défendu je mettrai derrière Benjamin
Biolet ouais moi aussi auudessus de
Benjamin Biolet allez on se met d'accord
là on se met d'accord derrière Johnny
non mais si si il a défendu il a fait
une concession accepté ouais d'accord je
fais que ça des concessions g Le voi sur
le chat concédez énormément vous concéz
peut-être trop allez-y c'est à vous je
crois Florent vous avez tiré Patrick je
crois non non ah non je crois céta
Olivier bon allez-y allez-y c'est
pasé Moné mon ah voilà Christophe
Christophe on en parler dans le chat
Christophe allez-y magnifique
extraordinaire il y a pas d'autres mots
c'est que c'est extraordinaire des mots
bleus même Aline qui est sur son premier
tube un blouse qui est extraordinaire
les mots bleus les paradis perdus un peu
menteur succès fou la dolchevita ou
Senorita vous avez écouté la reprise non
j'ai pas écouté la reprise rigol seorita
j'ai un peu de mal moi mais mais c'est
extraordinaire c'estd que même quand la
voix a baissé elle était encore très
touchante et il transmet des émotions
alors parait-il que c'était un type
hallucinant qui vivait la nuit moi j'ai
passé beaucoup de nuit chez lui ouou moi
aussi oui c'est vrai ouis moi fallit
fallait pas se lever tôt le lendemain
matin quand je partais vers 5h du matin
il m'engueulit mais tu pars déjà je bah
oui quand même je dois travailler demain
matin ah mais reste tu peux dormir ici
je te réveillerai quand j'irai me
coucher non un oiseau de nuit un vrai
original et puis contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent le contraire
d'un pososeeur il était totalement
authentique dans son personnage il y
avait pas plus authentique que lui et
moi c'est quelqu'un qui qui me manque
musicalement et personnellement parce
que je c'est un ovni qui a traversé
comme ça une
époque avec un
obsessionnel complètement eu puis qui s
intéressé à des trucs comme nanin
schnells Sude Alan
Vega c'est un foot BO aussi enfin qui a
eu des traversés du désert et qui est
revenu encore plus fort à chaque fois
quoi c'est on met où Christophe moi je
le mettrais devant Charles tren ah
devant Charles traîner ah oui
ouais moi ça me va aussi devant traîner
ouais h vous aussi devant ou juste en
dessous quoi en dessous de cher moi je
mettrai en dessous de cher ben on met
juste derrière Paul narf est-ce que ça
vous va comme ça on on s'accorde entre
ce que dit Florent et ce que vous dit
Olivier
allez juste ici et nous avançons avec
Christophe on continue
allez-y bien Laurent Vy oui il alors il
est très demandé dans le dans le chat
Laurent vzyy et d'ailleurs je cite
Michel Bro Bruel il nous casse les noix
C no Laurent V on parlait de maartn tout
à l'heure c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on a
de plus proche en terme de composition
ou là en France attention tenez sur
V c'est un c'est un super mélodiste un
super compositeur
euh on s'ennuie un peu avec vous
franchement non on s'ennuie pas il s ind
tous les 10 ans on s'enn pas on a pas le
temps non et puis alors quand même pour
moi c'est le tandem qui fonctionne c'est
V Souchon c'est on a le dro on a le
droit d'aimer l'un sans aimer l'autre
c'est génie du directeur artistique qui
les a réuni il faisait des des chansons
des singles dont les textes étaient
ineptes et les musiques formidables et
sous c'était l'inverse et cet homme a eu
l'idée de les réunir de dire mais toi tu
es for pour les musiques toi tu es fort
pour les textes moi je dirais que c'est
le binôme qui compte
vousou d'AC ça veut dire qu'on les
mettra côte à côte il va arriver tout à
l'heure alin Souchon il est dans ce dans
notre liste s Souchon c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas pareil on les met où on le met
où on commence par Laur mais vous it
mettrai verschampfort moi pas au-dessus
quand même mais et vous Nicolas Olivier
ouais ouais verschanfort aussi au chfort
oui parce qu'il arrivera avec Souchon de
toute manière souchan le le rejoindra
c'est parfait Nicolas en continue
peut-être que nous allons retrouver une
dame dans cette liste ah je crois pas
j'ai vu ce que vous avez
tiré Berni Berni bon voisin de
Trust Claude François Claude François
Claude François
Nicol rien rien rien rien même pas ces
reprises de Tam la motan ça pour moi
c'est pas
défendre je Toal vous alliez
lâcher pour moi c'est ce qu'il y a de
pire c'est ce qu'il y a d'absolument
pire pire de pire de tout c'est pire que
la bome nucléaire ce type là c'est qui a
pire musicalement c'est qu' pire c'est
c'est c'est je reprendais la définition
de Bachou ce type là il savait pas
chanter il savait pas écrire il Savit
pas danser il savait pas composer savait
rien faire à part être un horrible un
horrible mec qui a terrorisé des tas de
gens qui a quand même flirté plus que ça
qui s'est très mal conduit et puis qui
nous a pourri tous les mariag moi je
félicite les gens qui se marient et qui
passent pas de chanson de Claude
François sinon je vais pas leur mariage
c'est abominable c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est à côté d'Alida à côté d'Alida
c'est c'est Barbara d'Alida c'est
Barbara à côté ah oui c'estd que vous le
mettez là vraiment en dernière position
mais c'est la le pour moi c'est la lie
absolue Mo je je suis
d'accord allez avoir du mal mais allez-y
parce que vous allez être tout à fait
honorable je le sais Florent dans une
autre vie dans un autre média j'ai
classé l'intégralité des chansons de
Claude François avec un a priori
c'est-à-dire ce type ne sait faire que
des reprises et c'est absolument
horrible et cetera or on voit
l'intégralité l'intégralité donc il avit
vous êtes mazochiste franchement ça que
c'est un journaliste d'investigation
voilà beaucoup de travail euh un ces
reprises sont souvent meilleures que les
original
finir parce que parce qu'il accélère le
rythme il chante comme un canard les
canards du bois de Vincen chante mieux
que lui il a pas besoin d'accélérer le
Ry pource écoutez écoutez je vais à Rio
est meilleur que l'original point final
deuxièmement il y a des compositions
originales qui sont
formidabbles avec Pierre de laané c'est
formidable c'est de l'eau c'est du vent
c'est magnifique c'est de l'eau c'est du
vent c'est ce que vous P du vent c'est
et qui se termine avec Étienne rodagille
avec un album r il avait besoin de payer
seses impôt non non non vous pouvez pas
dire ça et Claude François c'est une
figure populaire qui traversera les
générations à chaque fois oui mais oui
mais vous n'aimez pas le peuple vous
n'aimez pas le peuple pas qu'est-ce que
j'aime le pop c'est dans la gueule de
l'autre non mais il a raison il a raison
on va dans n'importe quelle balle il a
du CL de Fr ou c'est pas un gage de
qualité et surtout ce n'est pas celui
que vous croyez écoutez non je pense
qu'il est pire que celui que je crois cl
Françis bon vous vous le classeriez même
derrière il a fait comme d'habitude
comme d'habitude un standard ah enfin il
a pas fait grand chose hein il a
participé comme d'habitude c'est coécrit
d'ailleurs c'est coécrit c'est composé
par Nicolas vous c'est quand même c'est
quand même la musique qui compte le plus
dans comme vous le mettez où bien euh
moi je le
mets après Boba après Boba alors et vous
FL non mais Florent je vais vous
défendre vous êtes battu contre moi
mettra devant Freel devant Freel oh non
moi je le mets 128e VO pas le classement
sais ce qu'on va faire on va le mettre
entre Dalida et Goldman c'est il va il
va sortir du classement oui mais
derrière fr il va aussi sortir jeassure
parce que quand il sort des 30 il n'est
plus classé il disparaît dans la nature
non non mais en dessous en dessous en
dessous en dessous loin loin loin loin
allez avançons c'est là que Vincent
Roson deit faire une coupure
d'électricité en H je l'ai mis je l'ai
mis devant devant Booba voilà il va
sortir du classement je suis désolé
Florent mais vous vous êtes battu
admirablement on continue à vous Olivier
ah c'est un scandale ouis alors sachez
que Florent bar va faire un petit papier
sur cette émission pour notre Top 30
vous je vaasser Francis
Cabrel ah ben là typiquement moi je
préfère les chansons de Cabrel fait par
G en
fait il au moins c'est
drôle jardin person si si si si si moi
je défendrai Cabrel bon allez-y vous
avez la main c'est parce que c'est un
musicien c'est c'est un homme qui qui
est fasciné par James Taylor et Jackson
Brown et qui a fait qui a fait de la
chanson c'est un des premiers d'ailleurs
qui qui a imposé de d'être une star
française par que c'est un des plus gros
vendeurs de disque en France là je
reprends un
argument non mais pardon non mais il a
il a réussi avec en étant en étant non
il a réussi ça en étant exigeant et en
restant dans sa campagne ce qui est très
honorable c'est quelqu'un qui a jamais
joué le le jeu du show business
absolument jamais il est hyper discret
un peu voilà c'est un homme discret qui
vend 2 millions à chaque fois et sans
aucune concession je trouve que et ma
mère l'adore ça et c'est un homme et
c'est un homme c'est un c'est un c'est
c'est un bonhomme en plus il se comporte
très il traite très bien les gens de ses
collaborateurs j'ai des amis qui ont
joué dans ces groupes ils m'ont dit
c'est c'est il met ses musiciens en
avantf encore une fois c'est moi ça ça
musique m'ennuie un peu vous êtes pourou
contre la
cor non mais bon Olivier assz bien c'est
c'est c'est une bonne adaptation
française d'une forme de musique
américaine que lui aime c'est-à-dire
c'estes singers son writer souvent avec
des guitares des guitares acoustiques il
le fait bien il est sympathique voilà bi
après on le met où on le met aprè frel
c'est ça vers Benjamin violet non non
auudessus quand même enfin ils sont pas
fan à
côté vous avez vous avez envoyé Claude
François aux oubliettes laisser la
main allez Olivier où vous vous le
classeriezv Francis Cabrel derrière
nouaro derrière nouaro ah oui non et
vous Nicola ah non moi je je sais
pas ça devient compliqué il commence à y
avoir des noms là ouais ouis ça se
complique ça se complique dites-nous sur
le chat ce que vous en pensez
francisqueabrel peut-être après Alain
champfort ou ou après dominiica je sais
pas je suis pasz fan est-ce que ça vous
va moi j'aurais mis devant Benjamin
Biolet donc ouais bon alors on va le
mettre on va le mettre devant Eddie
Mitchell est-ce que ça vous va oui c'est
bien allez c'est
bien quand même devant Eddie Mitchell
c'est une souff cette émission oui je
sais et regardez certains vont commencer
à sortir des 30 Booba sa place ne tient
plus qu'à un fil on continue c'est mon
ami c'est julette Armanet ah julette
Tanet une femme jeune Olivier allez-y
Florent c'est vous qui nous avez proposé
de la B
c'est c'est du Véronique Sanson version
2020 c'estàdire c'est de la c'est de la
composition euh populaire euh les textes
sont moins profonds la musique est un
peu moins élaboré que que veréronique
Sanson donc c'est un nzad de veréronique
Sanson mais c'est ce qui se fait de
mieux avec Clara vonique Sanson est en
2uxè position on peut être un c'est très
bien placé ou non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui vu le l'offre
avec Clara lucchani c'est quand même la
chanteuse qui s'en sort le mieux et qui
fait une musique moi que j'aime et que
mes mes compères n'aiment pas la musique
populaire voilà la musique populaire non
c'est c'est c'est une musicienne c'est
une bosseuse c'est une c'est une fille
qui effectivement très marqué par
François dire du mal parce que vous avez
toujours envie de l'interviewer et tout
alors que l' de François c'est facile
vous pouvez tler quoi hein non mais euh
Juliette harmanet je trouve qu'elle je
suis content qu'une fille comme ça est
son succès aujourd'hui voilà je trouve
que c'est PL et sur C c'est incroyable
en plus oui oui Nicolas vous avez pas
l'HE euh non mais c'est c'est moi je
trouve c'est pas mal ce qu'elle fait
elle mène bien sa barque c'est euh c'est
est-ce que est-ce que avec si peu de
temps de carrière on peut déjà la
classer dans le top 30 des plus grands
chanteurs français carrière ou mais moi
je la mettrai derrière Michel Sardou
Juste pour rire oui mais ça veut dire
devant Laurent non effectivement c'est
encore un peu jeune elle sorti deux
albums oui bon alors de albums c'est un
peu court voilà c'est ça le souci mais
mention spéciale c'est ça VO spé bon
est-ce qu'on la met devant fre par
exemple derrière fre derrière fre allez
devant Daniel Balavoine sa place devrait
pas tenir dans le 30 on continue c'est à
VOUS Nicolas et on avance
progressivement Booba va se classer
progressivement Michel Berger Michel
Berger tiens allons-y aïe aïe aïe
Florent baracoche la tête enfin vous
avez classé Véronique Sanson en deème
position vousz Michel Berg ces deux
composition ces deux compositions étalé
sur 30 ans et sur 50 chansons c'est
c'est toujours la même chanson la
groupie du pianiste c'est jouer du piano
debout c'est oh non c'est horrible trop
de piano oh là là c'est horri sur côté
non c'est c'est pas horrible mais je
comprends pas comment vous pouvez avir
classer vonic pardon mais classer vonic
s vonic s c'est beaucoup plus varié oui
elle est plus forte que berger c'est
évidentc mais elle lui doit beaucoup non
ah non do rien confond avec France Gal
oui voilà avec franceou au début de sa
carrière oui lebut il y a quoi il mais
ils sont ils sont ils démarrent il y en
a pas un qui est supérieur à l'autre et
elle le dépasse parce queelle a une
espèce de et puis c'est quand même le
type le moins crédible enchanteur du
monde c'est c'est trop joie trop propre
sur lui c'était un fan de rock CIT un
mec qui avait très bon goût
mais effectivement ça ça ça transpire
pas c'est limité ça transpire pas
Nicolas ça transpire pas non moi oui ça
transpire pas du tout non en plus je
trouve certaines paroles vraiment
indigigentes quoi c'est pas un bon c'est
pas un bon interprète c'est pas un bon
paraliier ou a a a a ah mais vous allez
le mettre très bas Michel Berger avec
jean-jaces Goldman c'est un peu la même
ouai c'est la même ouais la même
catégorie dire c'est dans la même
catégorie derrière Dalida qu ah non
quand même pas non c'est fait c'est fait
je je suis désolé de vous le dire vous
inquiétez pas ils vont disparaître du
top 30 assez rapidement tous ces
genslivier continue le prochain
éliminera sans doute Booba à moins que
ce soit C Catherine RER ah très bien
Catherine r une femme allezy c'est tout
simplement une des plus grandes
interprète de ce pays de tous les temps
de la chanson populaire je d'accord je
trouve qu' c'est à la fois Damia c'est à
la fois Nina Haen c'est Brigitte
Fontaine c'est et puisitamso c'est quand
même un groupe mais on parle d'itamoup
de Catherine
rangou mais bon de toute façon obligé de
les lier hein voyz non mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est une magnifique interprète
qui a changé beaucoup de choses dans ce
pays qui continue de porter le bon elle
elle a malheureusement pas réussi à
constituer un répertoire après la mort
de Fred Chichin mais ça reste une une
des plus grandes moi j'ai jamais été fan
des destime Mitsuko mais je leur
reconnais encore une fois ça c'est
quelque chose que j'aime bien chez les
musiciens cette capacité de de se
renouveler en permanence de changer de
style de musique euh bon c'est une c'est
c'est vraiment une grande chanteuse
c'est évident et puis en plus elle a
elle avait aussi une gestuelle sur scène
enfin céit FL non mais tout pareil
qu'Olivier alors on la met où bah faut
la mettre FL allez-y vous la classeriez
moi je la mettrai vers
Bachou ah oui c'est très bien à l'entrée
juste à la sortie du top 10 je sais pas
si ça convient Olivier derrière
Jean-Louis Murat
derrière Bachou quand même derrière
Bachou quand même ça va allez voilà
Catherine ranger elle risque de rester
dans ce top
30 Catherine Ringer juste derrière Alain
Bachou et Booba à qui on fait nos adieux
Claude François est sur la sal Orelsan
je pense que Orelsan va va virer CLA
François c'est pour moi
le le meilleur auteur de de comment dire
de contemporain enfin on est dans les 5
si dernières années Mo je suis pas un
fan de rap est-ce qu'on juge les plus
grands chanteurs ou les plus grands
auteurs bah on fait un mix oui mais bon
ch c'était pas un très très grand
chanteur à partir de là il est en tête
de not par Tex oui oui oui oui et moi je
n'aime pas le rap mais le seul rappeur
que je peux écouter c'est Orsan parce
que la qualité des textes et de la
musique r ah c'est pas du rap c'est du
slam rapam c'est la variété rap la
variété r varié trap c'est ça c'est la
variété urbaine place là dedans alors
vous le mettez vous vous l'aimez pas
j'ai jamais dit ça moi je vi des à
l'avoir défendu et je je trouve
qu'effectivement c'est un c'est un de
ceux qui raconte le mieux cette époque
absurde moi ce que je déplore chezelson
c'est la pauvreté des musiques derrière
voilà ça c'est pour le coup ce que je
déplore chez beaucoup beaucoup de
chanteurs français d'ailleurs c'est pas
mais je trouve que la proposition
musicale est pas du tout à la hauteur de
l'ambition du projet pour dire les
choses de manière un peu en
poulet moi je supporte pas cette diction
ah espèce
d'accent ouis je sais pas d' ça vient
parce je crois qu'il vient de C donc
j'ai des amis qui ont grandi à et je
leur ai dit mais est-ce que vous parlez
vous avez con
Nonu oui un peu comme ça quoi bon bref
donc moi c'est ritoire je je peux pas
non vous pouvez pas mais alors Florent
Olivier vous le placez où et puis et
puis Nicolas ça changera de le faire non
je vous je vous je vous laisse faut le
mettre vers vers armané parce que là
c'est pareil on il a quoi il y a tris
albums album pe plus longtemps quand
même
ouais juste devant Arman derrière fre
allez peut-être qu'il pourra rester dans
ce top 30 Orelsan c'est pas impossible
Olivier nuuc alors je lis quand même ce
qu'on nous dit le plus grand c'est
anavour il est pas encore arrivé on
verra ce que ce qu'on pense le Figaro
vous savez il y a des gens qui modérent
notre chat la modération se désolidarise
de la chute de Sardou ils sont d'accord
avec vous au réseau sociau du Figaro mon
cher Léo Ferré ah attention débat vous
avez la main Nicolas moi ça m'ennuie
mais
mais mais c'est compliqué parce que
c'est un homme c'est c'est un artiste
éminemment respectable qui lui aussi
a officié dans des genres assez variés
moi j'ai des amis qui sont vraiment des
des fous dingues de léopéré et mais moi
c'est c'est bon c'est pas c'est pas mon
truc quoi ou c'est pas vot cam mais
c'est vrai moi je suis d'accord avec
vous je m'ennuie un peu j'arrive pas pe
mal VI aussi moi je suis très fan je
suis très fan je je suis assez
inconditionnel parce que il y a un
souffle à la fois lui pour le coup c'est
C musique à égalité c'est un des rares
en France qui a qui a autant misé sur
l'un que sur l'autre avec un autre qui
est ginsbourg et euh c'est bon ben il a
signé quand même une des plus grandes
chansons pour moi avec le temps c'est
une des plus grandes chansons française
de de de tous les temps sans jeu de mot
à chaque fois que je replonge dans
Ferret je me dis
c'est c'est visionnaire c'est c'est un
peu daté mais en même temps il a quand
même une carrière très très longue il y
a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de choses
il y en a un peu pour tout tout le monde
chez fer et vous Florent non moi je suis
assez d'avis de Nicolas je reconnais le
monstre sacré moi ça me touche pas
particulièrement à part deux trois
chansons et je trouve ça un peu mal
viilli ou vous le mettrez où vous tous
les deux et puis Olivier essera de le
faire remonter non mais après B la vie
d'Olivier m'intéresse parce que je veux
dire bon Ferré c'est Ferré quoi on peut
pas impossible de le on va pas le mettre
aprèsan bon
euh je sais pas vous mettriez vers Alain
champfort vous messieur moi je le
mettrais je le mettrai euh vous me dites
quand vous avez choisi mais entre 5
entre la 5e et la 20e place quoi quel Mo
je le mets dans le top 10 moi
je faut le mettre devant B je pense oui
allez devant ouais voilà ouais c'est pas
mal ça magnifique vous accordez vous
avez trouvé votre ride de croisière je
trouve on continue allez on avance
messieurs bientô midi et c'est à Olivier
Olivier oui je sais vous avez du boulot
et oui l'é oui l'actualité avec la CMP
jacqu Dron Jacques duutron on y va vous
m'avez dit que c'était compliqué Nicolas
pourquoi c'est compliqué parce que parce
que
Duron Duron c'est 15 chansons en gros
euh PA et et que il le dit lui-même en
interview Olivier l' interviewé
plusieurs fois moi je l'ai intervieé il
y a quelques semaines il fait de la il
il faisait de la musique pour amuser ses
potes c'est une bonneé ça donc donc oui
mais alors bon comme c'est du Tron ça
passe bien mais parfois on est pas loin
de la godriole quand même je veux dire
le drager des supermarchés ESTP et l'
l'ESS de l'
mais bon donc bon Dron est tellement
sympathique en plus avec ses yeux bleus
là c'est cette gueule incroyable
tellement charismatique aussi
musicalement il reste pas grandchose moi
quand pour pour l'interview j'ai écouté
ces trucs des années 70 il reste rien
vous Olivier allez on essaie d'acc je
suis d'accord avec Nicolas Mme même si
c'est un des types les plus ismatique
jamais avir fou une scète oui oui ça
compte ça c'estra et puis une attitude
géniale enfin il a tout compris quoi
c'est oui mais je suis assez d'accord il
y a qu'un chanson il suprime Paris Paris
séveille et je le mettrai à la 18e place
moi place devant Dominique A mais
derrière
chanfort il va pas être content il va
être vexé d'être derrière son ancien
pianiste ben on peut le mettre devant si
vous voulez dev ah non non non mais
comparé à la carrière de chanfort non
mais là vous aimez les gens populaires
il est très populaire mais depuis il a
plus rien fait depuis ça n'empêche pas
la tourné devant chfor ou derrière
chanfort c'est vous qui AZ tranché
devant chfort devant chfor c'est
tranché ou bien allez on continue
Florent on avance Jacques Duron qui
vient d'exclure à l'instant Michel
Berger ah voilà charlaz navour charlaz
navour alors là bon pour moi c'est le
plus grand ah c'est vous c'est le plus
grand est-ce que là il y a un vrai sujet
ce qu'il peut détronner George brass
pour vous c'est oui oui il y a tout un
tas de chansons de tub de textes qui
sont incroyables qui ont une résonance
sur nos vies euh moi je trouve que
laabem hier encore
euh c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire pour moi c'est un best
off après il y a aucun tube après les
plaisirs démodés qui est quand même de
78 euh malheureusement c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait trop de disque trop de
chansons moyenne trop de concerts ratés
je suis désolé moi j'avais beaucoup
d'estime d'admiration mais il a il a
joué les prolongations on l'a trop il
s'est dilué je trouve qu'il s'est dilué
ça peut compter là là je vous comprends
quand vous me
dites ans donc heusement oui mais il a
joué à berc à 92 enfin il était quand
même dans une compétition et la musique
n'est pas une compétition Nicolas il a
rayonné à l'étranger he ça c'est un
c'est important chanteur françaisoui
rayonnement de la France compte compte
dans donnéour c'était bon moi après je
suis pense comme Olivier c'està-dire
c'est c'est c'est c'est un best of de 15
15 chansons et oui oui oui je suis
d'accord mais moi je trouve qu'il en
fait un peu dans sa mè de chanter je
trouve qu'il en fait toujours un peu
trop et je préfère les PE plus bien
compris vous vous vous ne le ferez pas
passer devant George brassin je crois
qu'ils sont en majorité mais vous le
mettez où parce que dans les 10 oui dans
les dans les tro dans les trois
minimum et le rayonnement de la France
vous avez raison Nicolas ça compte vous
pouvez pas moi je mettrai derrière
traîner derrière traîner et vous moi je
le mettrai peut-être après brassin après
brassin ouais ben moi je suis d'accord
devant parce que effectivement sur la
longueur c'est pas mais mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est allez est-ce qu'on le met
derrière Véronique Sanson en plus c'est
un bon acteur allez on le met derrière
vonique sans un super acteur oui oui
magnifique et Barbara qui sort du podium
on continue charlaz naavour n'aura donc
pas détroné George BR ah c'est moi il
intègre ce ce podium et ce top 30
Aznavour les gens sont fans sur dans le
chat Gilbert BCO encore non on l' déjà
fait Gilbert il fait deux fois est-ce
que c'est truqué fin c'est pas truqué
bien sûr que non et nous avons Bertrand
Belin Bertrand Belin h ça va être
difficile Olivier NUC je sais que vous
l'aimez beaucoup
oui bah oui peut-être pas dans les dans
les 20 premiers mais en tout cas il a
une carrière très longue moi c'est
quelqu'un que je connais que je suis
depuis la fin des années 80 qui a été
musicien qui qui est un super musicien
super guitariste il s'est à peu près
tout joué il a fait c'est un c'est un
c'est un vrai aventurier de la musique
avec un parcours assez incroyable et il
s'est révélé sur le tard chanteur à
l'âge de 40 ans peut-être et avec des
textes abscond mais une langue très
original c'est un sacré chanteur c'est
un excellent guitariste estce vous où
vous le classeriez moi je le classerai
ben je prétends pas le mais je le classe
derrière Benjamin Biolet derrière
Benjamin Biolet est-ce que ça vous va
moi je connais aucune chanson de lui
donc je ou je m'fface ou ça vous va
personne derrière lui faites passer non
ouis vous vous effacez moi j'aurais mis
quand même si non quand même Johnny ENF
non je sais pas John ben der Benjam
comis ah ouès bien ça vous va Nicolas
ouais ouais moi aussi ou oui oui oui non
non non non mais j'aime bien j'aime bien
Belin je suis pas un fanatique mais je
monieurs il nous reste un quart d'heure
on a 10 non à faire on est capable on
fait allez on y va c'est
partiivier je sais et vous avez raison
de mettre berbin je sais pas il peut
sauver sa place encore c'est pas
impossible ber on a dit qu'on mettait
avec a déjà parlé et bien voilà on
accélère Alain Souchon pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent vous savez qu'on en a
déjà parlé vous remontez un peu dans le
dans le live et il est c'est un gros
morceau là Serge ginbourg aïe a a a
c'est pas un gros morceau c'est le gros
morceau c'est probablement le chanteur
français qui aujourd'hui a le plus de
d'impact point alors c'est l'un de ceux
qui a le moins vendu
ou parce que la chanson l'histoire de
Melody Nelson qui est un disque culte en
Angleterre aux États-Unis et C che chez
les musiciens je veux dire c'est pour ça
qu'on peut pas le mettre plus grand
chanteur parce que comme il pas si il a
oui mais il a chanté ça compte hein ou
pour moi il est numéro 2 ah numéro 2
pour moi je moi je l'aurais mis
au-dessus de Paul narf mais ah pas mieux
pas mieux ouais ouais 6e ah moi je mets
audessus de Véronique Sanson quand même
numéro 2 numéro 2 numéro 2 oui mais il a
de numéro 2 et il y a un contre
Florent deux ou tro mais pas plus bas
allez TR vous êtes prêts à
descendre on va mettre gbourg en dessous
de vonique
Sanson un peu absurde non mais il il FL
je suis prêt à transiger sur numéro 2
vous êtes Serge gbourg en deè position
ou un bis un
bis après voilà le en fait vous avez mis
que des anards quoi George brassin gbour
ou bon sans c'est peut-être moins le cas
mais on a Atton elle est droite hein il
pas de douteou Oui Oui elle vient d'être
raoutée en direct sur le F non elle est
fille d'un député gouliste non puis elle
jamais caché ces c'estes non Serge
ginbourg est-ce que pour l'instantb
n'était pas de gauche non plus
d'ailleurs est-ce que pour l'instant ce
classement vous convient Olivier vous
étiez sceptique est-ce que ça vous
paraît queain de faire mais il y a
beaucoup de morts comme prévu oui oui
mais absolument à part veronix Sanson
les 10 premiers sont morts ouais ouais
ouais non
Willam non plus non non mais B presque
ils sont morts musicalement peut-être on
continue euh Serge gbourg vient donc
détrôner c'est à moi Véronique Sanson à
la 2uxè place Véronique Sanson va-t-elle
s'accrocher au podum orurel SAN est sur
la cè pour le top 30 alors gros morceau
aussi François hardardi François
hardardi ah donc moi je suis euh très
fan mais sur une période assez
courte voilà mais bon des album comme la
question tout ça c'est c'est formidable
euh après euh la fin des années 70 les
années 80 90 je connais pas très bien ce
que j'ai entendu m'a pas bouleversé mais
c'est quand même un sacré monument quoi
ça c'est vrai alors on parlait de succès
à l'étranger c'est la chanteuse
française la plus connue au monde ah oui
c'est l'emblème de la France en de de
mat peut-être en vivant ah oui ah ou non
pour moi elle est elle est dans le top 5
oui évidemment François hardardi un
parcours et et moi j'ai écouté les
albums récents il y a toujours de très
bonnes chansons même sur les albums
récents il y a jamais elle n jamais fait
un mauvais disque il y a pas il y a
aucune chanson indigne il y a une
élégance il y a cette voix qui est quand
même extraordinaire ces textes moi ma
chanson préférée c'est partir quand même
c'est une musique de Jacques Duron texte
de François hardardi c'est pour ça mvec
vous la mettrez ah oui vous la mettrez
aussi B que ça moi je la mettrai avec
jaces duutron 20
ouais est dans Top 10 mais moi je l'aime
beaucoup mais euh c'est pas
extraordinaire en terme de musique c'est
mais si c'est fabuleux les paroles sont
très belles mais fabuleux si si
si non elle a toujours été entouré
d'excellents compositeurs vous la
mettrez dans Top 10 mais vous allez
quand même pas la mettre sur le podium
non dans le top 5 moi je la
mets on pe pas la mettre devant Paul
narf et Christophe quand même
non Nicolas vous en pensez quoi moi dans
dans le voisinage de Paul narf et
Christophe et ben vous savez quoi on la
met entre les deux oui voilà par exemple
comme ça tout le monde est content vous
pas trop non mais c'est un scandale je
suis en train de me faire avoir mais pas
du tout attendez il était la mre il
était prêt Olivier tu prêt à la mettre
sur le podium vous en 20e position on la
met 10 transigé et je pensais qu'à un
moment vous deviez vous impliquer dans
le classement ouais mais moi je suis pas
un grand fan j'aime beaucoup François
hardardy mais bon ça me fait pas tomber
de ma chaise je je me lève pas la nuit
pour l'écouter mais bon en même temps
voyez bon on continue
allez-y François hardardi que je
classe donc on a dit ah France Gal tiens
donc vous vous avez hé la tête qu'est-ce
qui se passe bah c'est dans le même sac
que Michel Berger quoi ils sont
tellement liés que grand interprète
grand inter grand
interprète après elle n'est rien sans
Michel Berger c'est met pas dans Top 30
si quand même si si si ah si mais parce
que Michel Berger est sorti du Top 30
lui 3 par donc il a dis met entre Edie
et Johnny
non France Gal ouais ouais
compé non moi j'aime bien faire hurler
tout le monde moi j'aime bien quelques
tubes de la fin des C donc il doivent
rien du tout à Michel
Berger mais après non ça me ça me laisse
ouais ouais je crois que là vous arerez
pas à la faire rentrer dans le top 30
France Gal ne rentre pas on est vous
deux non et vous allez la mettre
tellement B parce que là en plus on va
perdre Johnny on va per non non c'est
vrai on peut pas perdre Johnny je fer
tout pour sauver Johnny quoi qu'il
arrive là et là c'est difficile quand
même c'est difficile j'en conviens ce
soir je ne dors pas est une très belle
chanson par contre allez-y
edit Piaf edit Piaf attention edit Piaf
monument Florent baraco vous en faites
qui c'est monument oui c'est dans le top
3 obligatoirement bah pas
obligatoirement on peut décider que oui
vous pouvez décider autrement comme
Charles navour charour moi c'est ouais
mais pour moi charlesaz naavour eted
Piaf fa oui mais là on est sur quand
même des références très très vieillotes
oui mais marqu l' c'est très viill edit
Pier quelqu'un écoute edit pierf jamais
moi on
a la fois n'importe quel américain qui
vient à Paris Mo il y a que dans les
restaurants français à New York que
j'entends edit Piaf non mais ladyedy
Gaga a repris edit Piaf oui mais il y a
c'est-à-dire que sa musique vit au-delà
d'elle c'est-à-dire que il y a des gens
qui la repr c'est la chanson la
peut-être la plus connue la chanson
française la plus connue c'est la vie en
rose et pas adapté oui oui oui ou c'est
vrai l'yne à l'amour c'est pas mal
aussour non mais bien sûr mais mais moi
je pense que c'est top 3 c'est top 3
c'est top 3 Nicolas vous en faites quoi
vous moi top 6 quelque part dans le top
6 mais naavour derrière devant
der C je vais faire hurler Olivier mais
moi que que que Piaf soit après
Véronique Sanson ça
me ça para bizarre quoi aïe a a a a
Olivier mais je vois très bien les
arguments d'Olivier c'est priviléger ce
qui ce qui ce que les gens écoutent
encore ce ce qu' vit encore mais moi je
la mettrai entre Barbara et traîné oui
c'est bien aussi ouais bon est-ce qu'on
la met juste après juste devant Charles
naavour non non bah vous lâcherez pas
moi je suis assez d'accord avec vous
Florent c'està-dire que c'est si on doit
demander à n'importe quel américain
brésilien ne nous appelez pas nous dans
ce cas-là fait un fait un fait faites
une émission avec des touristes et là
vous aurez tout à fait autre chose nous
sommes pas touristes vous nous appelez
vous nous dérangez vous nous prenez 2
heures de notre temps pour débattre on
va débattre on est re spécialistes si
c'est pour avoir la vie de de allez-y
mais mais j'essaie de prendre les avis
mais non on a on a pris du temps pour ce
classement donc on va donc vous vous la
mettez en 6e j'ai dit entre Barbara et
traet et vous
ouaccord non Mo ça me va Barbara traet
oui oui non ah vous transigez devant
Barbara battez-vous pour la mettre
devant Barbara ouais au moins devant
barbaraiv Barbara Barbara Barbara est
plus original et plus influente sur
aujourd'hui queedit
per c'est maintenant que je m'engage je
décide parce que je donne ma voix à edit
Piaf et on va la mettre devant Barbara
Flor parfait merci voilà messieur il
s'est battu vous avez vu toutes les
couaves qui avalé fr depuis le début de
cette cette émission c'est pas fini oui
mais il en reste très peu non mais déjà
je suis très cont j'ai sauvé
mich qui va rester dans le top 30 allez
on continue il nous en reste que
quelquesuns on fait ça
rapidement alors Jean Guidoni donc moi
je connais son fils l'imitateur mais je
connais pas gu Michel Guidoni
des Guidoni mais que fait ce nom dans
c'est un grand c'est un grand c'est un
grand qui qui a beaucoup apporté dans
les années 80 magnifique chanson un
texte texte de Pierre Philippe
euh grand univers c'est sombre c'est
c'est on est on n'est pas loin du café
théâtre moi c'est avec une voix
magnifique ça c'est un pour moi c'est un
grand chanteur français Jean guidonier
vous avez envie de le mettre dans S
France je ne connais pas je suis désolé
jamais entendu une ch le connaissent pas
non mais bon et moi je je suis pas bon
en CH français en revanche Olivier a eu
raison de nous en parler maisi non plus
je connaissais pas pour tout vous dire
est-ce que vous mettez ber trambelin par
exemple oui pour qu'il par dans
Dansin
derre allez bon ben d'accord je je le
mets je le mets Jean Guidoni on continue
allez-y
Nicolas chis je c j'ai pas céit pas moi
m' vol mon céit pas pas moi V
fermière milen Farmer que faiton milen
Farmer ou vous allez me sortir
l'argument de la popularité donc sur la
popularité c'est la meilleure sur la
créativit it c'est la pire d'accord mais
je suis assez d'accord on est tous
d'accord ah donc on ne parle même pas de
milen Farmer d'accord et ben on écarte
milen Farmer qui r pas dans c'eston
faulter oui peut-être peut-être
peut-êtreard c'est un cas intéressant
allez-y que fait-on Gérard pour moi là
c'est votre
momentard c'est votreure non je suis pas
seul sur je serai pas seul je sais que
Nicolas connait c'est quand même un
chanteur culte on peut on peut le dire
bien sûr il a pas fait vier le Top 50 il
a eu un tube qui quand même un classique
de la chanson française qui il voyage à
solitaire et un deuxième tube qui est
marine bar qui pas une grande chanson
c'est une carrière ça fait partie de ces
gens qui ont pas vendu beaucoup d' mais
qui ont énormément influencé leur
contemporain sans lui il y aurait pas
Dominica il y aurait pas Jean-Lou Mura
il a commencé en même temps que cheller
cheller lui lui doit beaucoup il y
aurait pas la moitié du classement sans
Mans Mans vous en faites quoi Nicolas
euh pour moi c'est une carrière assez
courte mais après j'ai pas très très
bien j'ai pas suivi de près ce qu'il a
fait après le le son âge d'or entre
guillemets jusque au début an 70 quoi
voilà euh mais oui c'est un c'est un
personnage vraiment culte il y a des
gens figure au magazine comme gen Ren
ver platen qui sont r dingue de Jean mur
et au quotidien aussi qui tuit père mère
pour V vrai ouais ouis alors on le met
où est-ce qu'on le met top 20 top 20
ouais ah oui vous avez envie de le
mettre dans le top 20 vous Florent moi
je mettra après Michel Sardou ouais
mettra après Michel Sardou allez ben
c'est très bien en 19e position c'est
parfait ça vous va ouais et ben on
continue allez-y c'est à VOUS Olivier il
me semble ben oui par que j'ai passé mon
tour tout à
l'heure Bertrand burgala Bertrand
burgala mais alors c'est vraiment votre
moment non moi je suis fan ah vous êtes
fan aussi bah allez-y vous avez la main
sur Bertrand burgala bah Bertrand
burgala est quelqu'un qui fait une
musique qui ne ressemble à aucune autre
en France actuellement qui a souvent des
paroles qui sont pas toujours écrites
par lui d'ailleurs que je trouve
absolument magnifique il fait une
musique très poétique que certains
idiots ont qualifié de Easy Listening
alors c'est pas du tout du Easy
Listening c'est lui-même plutôt un fan
de rock progressif et de l'école de
Canterburry c'est une musique que je
trouve très intéressante c'est technique
là j'ai j'ai dit au début j'ai dit au
début de l'émission j'écoutais quasiment
jamais de musique chantée en français
burgala je l'écoute régulièrement ah
vous l'écoutez ah ça ça m'intéresse il a
un point commun avec Michel SARD ah
c'est qu'il a eu des textes écrits par
Laurent chalumo ah oui ouais c'est vrai
vous en faites quoi je connais pas assez
bon ben alors vous voulez le mettre
juste derrière Michel Sardou ça vous va
t qu'on les CL du derère Michel s
peutêre non c'est peut-être haut non
quand
même moi je le mettrai entre chanfort et
Dominica entre chanft et Dominica vous
savez que vous allez me sortir mon
Johnny alidé hein j'espère qu'il y a
Julien claire en fait parce que va arver
AR ouais chanf entre chanfant et
dominicain je trouve c'est bien ouais en
plus allez c'est parti vous sa ce que je
vais
faire ouais fa attention ou là h top 30
pour moi h top 30 non il est quand même
dedans parce qu'il a il a alors il a eu
il a eu un âge d'or il a eu un âge d'or
malheureusement lui il pense qu'il est
encore dans son âge d'or là il est dans
l'âge vermeille
euh non moi j'ai je il a apporté une un
langage c'est vrai que il a pas inventé
l'argot mais il a popularisé Nicolas ah
si non non Renault c'est un c'est moi
moi j'aime pas Renault mais je pense
qu'il a
p parce qu'il a ouais il je mettrai 15e
moi truc de tit parisien ouais bon alors
15e pour Olivier nu vous top 30 on peut
trouver un un juste milieu Nicolas
devant Mans ou après Mans ouais derrière
Michel Sardou est-ce que ça vous va non
audessus de Sardou non non non on peut
pas mettre auessus Sardou pas mettre
renusargum la popularité pour le coup là
il le gagne parce que c'est c'est quand
même un homme qui ne sait plus chanter
qui remplit des salles depuis 20 ans il
sa'est plus chané il rempl ça c'est un
des Français les plus aimés il vont pas
il vont il est prêt à le mettre en
dehors du top 30 il accepte de mettre
top 30 juste derrière Michel Sardou ça
vous va ou pas Nic en plus ils se sont
longtemps
détestéili rigolo ça vous va bon on n
pas on est là il y a pas un enjeu énorme
aour de la de la 20e place mais
attention Johnny ALID est en danger Jin
que fait-on Jin moi j'aime bien oui vous
aimez bien je sais moi aussi mais bon
c'est un peu je pense que c'est un peu
démodé bah c'est complètement Démé
excusez-moi il a fait on parlait de
chanson connu à l'étranger les
chansélisées tout le monde connaittou
une reprise c'est une reprise d'accord
si on se retrouve tous entre français
dans un
camping et que les Italiens nous
demandent de chanter une chanson on
chantera tous les ch ce sont des
reprises c'est l'éta Indiens et les Ch
il était indien et tout ch non c'est
très c'est très hasbine pris des trucs
de Tony
j ouais pas un grand chanteur pas de top
30 pour Jodin que fait-on de Diams bah a
plus de carrière Diams
arrêté mais enfin c'est la chanteuse la
plus culle des années 2000 ouais mais
c'est loin les années 2000 oui mais bon
ça suffit vous m'avez parlé des années
70 ça des années
70 vous aussi ah vous êtes vous êtes dur
que fait-on de Brigitte Fontaine on la
met dans le top 30 la Metz dans Top 30
vous savez que johnnyid va sortir du
sorti par Brigit fontaine c'est quand
même non mais c'est elle est géniale
elle est totalement géniale il y en a il
y a un grand absent c'estelin aussi oui
mais alors on n pas pu mettre tout le
monde alors attendez Brigitte Fontaine
peut-elle vraiment sortir dealid du top
30 ni je connais trop mal son je peux
pas m'exprimer je peux pas moi je peux
pas moi pas parce que je connais mal son
que je dis il faut sortir du top 30 je
connais très trs sortiridée du top
30 est entre nous ça fera parler au
moins ou ça fera parler ça fera parler
vous la mettez où Brigit fontaine j'ai
envie de vous faire
plaisiron je la mets je la
mets en dessous de Dominica ah bon ça va
en dessous de Dominica on est donc à la
la 28e place elle peut faire son
apparition et garder sa place il m'en
reste deux que fait-on de je l'ai perdu
Jul et ben je prends Julien clair ah
mais Julien clair
allez-y c'est c'est la
composition c'est incroyable et servis
par des très grands textes de rodagil ce
qu'il le dessert je pense que c'est
toutabad ce qu'il le dessert c'est toute
la décennie 80 où il c'est un peu perdu
cœur de rockur mais sinon c'est
extraordinaire l'album numéro 7 c'est un
cheeduvre c'est vrai euh terre de France
une chanson incroyable la préférée de
François mitéran ah oui et surtout il y
a une anecdote il y a un retour dans les
années 90 où il se réconcilie avec avec
ragile l'album à quoi sert une chanson
si elle est désarmé pour moi c'est top
10 c'est top 10 il l' très bien défendu
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
l'air sympathique mais moi j'ai
l'impression quand il chante j'ai
l'impression qu'on torture une chèvre
donc non mais ça c'est un cliché c'est
pas possible mais non mais c'est
vraiment moi je le mettrai derrière
Bachou derrière Bachou
euh on trouve ah oui en 16e position 17e
position vous vous le feriez descendre
un peu non mais non mais c'est moi c'est
j'aime pas sa VO ça veut pas dire que
j'aime pas sa musique ou que je trouve
qu'il est nul non mais vous êtes là pour
donner votre avis Nicolas vous mettriez
top 10 mais en même temps c'est un juste
Milie moi je le mettrais en dessous de
Christophe voilà et donc ça me Olivier
nu sans trouver un équili
moi je mettrai après Bachou
mais comment peuton classer Julien clair
en dessous François hardard on
peut fait comme ça et j'ai un dernier
nom à vous proposer que faiton de J la
plus grande star actuelle c'est vrai
c'est la plus grande star actuelle elle
fer sortir Francis Cabrel donc moi je
suis assez
tenté mais bon c'est une blague quoi
c'est pas la peine qu'on épil mauvaise
blague plusaise blue fa parire du tout
du tout AZ c'est sinistre mais non j'ai
pas d'humour pourquoi mais la musique
c'est une chose sérieuse B oui messieurs
nous avons notre Top 30 George brassins
et donc selon vous selon Le Figaro le
plus grand chanteur français de tous les
temps devant Serge gbourg et Véronique
Sanson Charles Aznavour redit Piaf les
mythes se classe 4e et 5e Barbara 6e
Charles traet 7e Paul narf 9e au grand
désarrois de for baraco François
hardardi et dans le top 10 juste devant
Christophe un grand absent peut-être
deux Johnny HID est exclus du top 30 non
ça c'est c'est un scandale non mais ça
c'est un scandale oui vous avez honte
j'ai honte et je me désolidarise de
cette émission non et vous Olivier vous
avez pas honte non moi je suis fier
qu'on a quatre femmes dans le top 10
super alors qu'on a eu il y a beaucoup
moins de femmes dans ce dans dans notre
présélection est-ce que vous trouvez ça
dommage de pas avoir dealid et vous moi
je m'en fous complètement il s'en fout
complètement FL je regrette un peu moi
je suis désespéré on n'est pas rendu
hommage à Guy Marchand quoi mais
formidable chanteur formidable chanteur
mais non non moi Johnny alidday j'ai dit
ce que j'en pensais je changerai pas
d'avis on je vais me faire insulter par
les par les inter ou mais on a
l'habitude voilà ou ouais anonyme je me
désabonne du Figaro on a perdu un abonné
à cause de vousable de sortir Johnny
d'un classement sur les churs français
une honte en majuscule voilà ce qu'on ce
qu'on nous dit euh Sylvain Chatelin qui
dit faites ce que vous voulez mais vous
n'avez pas le droit de sortir Cabrel
Cabrel sauve sa tête à la 30e place
merci monieur moi je trouve qu'il a de
la gueule le Class oui trve ah ben ouais
vous étiez un peu sceptique et pu
finalement ça vous plaî voilà puis vous
Sardou est top 20 ça va vous avez fait
votre petit coup en enlevant Johnny HID
et Jean-Jacques Goldman vous êtes
content tous les deux et vous Michel
Sardou Michel Sardou et pu franchement
le top 10 il se regarde il s'écoute
surtout ou ou merci beaucoup msieurs
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi vous
avez passé un bon moment cé je sais que
vous devez remonter parce qu'il y a une
CMP un autre conclave un peu plus
important trava oui oui oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai merci beaucoup merci de nous
avoir suivi excellente après-midi sur le
Figaro c'est compliqué quand un votre
truc